nancy pelosi
is ordering masks to be worn on the
house floor or technically
in the congress building where she has
the authority i guess there was some a
funny stunt pulled off by some
republicans where they're like well she
has no
jurisdiction on the senate side so they
like stood in the middle of the building
but yeah she's saying if you don't wear
a mask you'll be arrested
she has ordered the capitol police to
arrest staff and visitors for not
wearing masks
i guess the instructions when it comes
to house members is to
notify somebody oh no they're breaking
the rules well the republicans pushed
back and a large group went
and refused to wear masks but of course
washington dc has now brought back their
mask mandates nevada's brought back
their mask mandates
and it seems like lockdowns i i
i think we're we're gonna see lockdowns
mitch mcconnell was alluding to that
saying if we don't
get everybody vaccinated it's gonna be a
lot like it was last year
and some people arguing he meant with
the deaths and other people are saying
he means the lockdowns and i think he's
meaning the lockdowns
but here we go i mean you look at right
now one of the biggest challenges
is that there's endless contradictory
information coming out from
news organizations from medical experts
and the whole thing is just static at
this point it's all noise now i can't
tell you why that is
and i can't tell you what what what the
latest numbers are because
you know we were talking here before the
show and we're like giving conflicting
information because the news reports
coming out
you could have someone from the cdc say
you know x equals two
yesterday and then today some writer
sees that writes up the news story and
it goes live at 11 p.m
right at the same time there's a press
conference press conference with another
doctor saying x equals three
and now you have two conflicting stories
from mainstream news outlets and no one
has any idea
what's going on some people have said
the noise is on purpose
so that no one can know what's really
happening and then everything just falls
apart so i got to say stakehomes
you nailed it there is a massive
distrust in this country and society is
is collapsing but uh i'd go a little bit
further than you stake them
frozen aren't familiar staccum's the the
stake brand for some reason put out this
big
thread about the american existential
crisis we're facing with polarization
and uh i think we've hit that mark i
think joe biden's approval rating
between democrats and republicans just
shows
that no one cares what's true they right
now just
well i shouldn't say that they both care
about what's true but both claim that
they're right the other side is wrong
personally i think one side is more
right than the other it's why
independent voters
tend to disapprove of joe biden because
when you actually look at what's going
on but
regardless a lot of people just won't
believe anything
so here we go there's going to be a
i don't know stakehomes if if you are
right about what's happening
then we're going to get to a point where
this problem can never be solved
although i i think we're probably past
that point so we'll be talking about
that stuff
we are being joined by carol markowitz
columnist for the new york post
how's it going do you want to introduce
yourself real quick hi i'm carol
markowitz i'm a columnist at the new
york post
[Music]
i also write a bunch of other places uh
often so
check it out my twitter page all right
we got ian hello everyone he's back here
i'm back i've arrived
let's roll yeah and i'm here in the
corner as well pushing buttons excited
to hear what carol has to say
before we get started my friends head
over to timcast.com and become a member
in order to get to get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim castro podcast we'll have a bonus
segment up later tonight
where we'll get a little bit spicier
because youtube would ban us depending
on you know what we talk about and here
they got a bunch of rules and we can
speak more freely at timcast.com but
also you get an ad free experience we're
writing tons of
journalism with a bunch of new
journalists and if you want to support
that work be a member don't forget
you can like this video subscribe to
this channel and share the show with
your friends if you think we do a good
job and want to support our work
let's read this first story and talk
about what's going on here in the
capitol with nancy pelosi
the story from timcast.com house arrests
capitol police instructed to arrest
staff and visitors
not wearing face masks a new memo
circulated on capitol hill this week
after the cdc revised its guidelines for
vaccinate americans
instructing police to arrest visitors
and staff
who refuse to wear face masks in certain
areas
quote although this applies to the
members of congress
officers should not arrest any member
for failure to wear a mask
or to comply with the mask mandate the
guidance states any member who fails to
comply with a request to wear a mask
should be reported to the house sergeant
at
arm's office quote this is such an
overstep of speaker pelosi's authority
to basically make our capital police
arrest staff members
and report on members of congress rep
kat
kamik told fox news thursday it's
absolutely unconscionable
that this is where we're at i cannot
comply with tyrannical order chemic edit
this is the people's house not nancy
pelosi's house
the speaker of the house does not
control the u.s capitol police
pelosi spokesperson drew hamill told fox
news we were unaware of the memo
until it was reported to the press quote
if you're a capital police officer you
got orders
if a vaccinated staffer comes comes
across in the house side without a mask
you're ordered to arrest them but not on
the senate side
house minority leader kevin mccarthy
said this is not the america we know
so we're seeing that uh steve steve
scalise said it was pelosi directing
police to arrest vaccinated people
and ike you know they're saying she
doesn't control the police
they didn't that's a non-denial denial
yeah saying oh but she doesn't control
the police yes but you can go to them
and say i've ordered all masters to be
worn and they said okay all right we'll
go arrest them so there's a big
difference between her
controlling them and instructing what
the rules are
i can't imagine that it's not pelosi
because if it was the capital police
making this decision
then the senate side would be equally as
affected which it's not
i'm just glad democrats have found found
some policing to approve of i i would
think that you know they can send in
some social workers here
to get the masking on but i don't know
why we need to get the police and the
sergeant-at-arms involved
actually i mean that would be a
brilliant stunt to be hilarious right
yeah like matt gates is walking through
the house chamber or whatever
and then a social worker comes out and
like takes a knee and says like matt
is something wrong but they don't know
how to they don't have to do funny
things like that
i'll tell you what this story really
freaked me out because
it's it's dangerously close to
you know it's dangerously close to an
old story
of a man being caned in congress you
know the story no yeah back during the
civil war
there was a caning that one rap was like
beating the other for the game now i
don't think nancy plays gonna come out
beat anybody
and i'm not suggesting anyone's gonna be
violent what i'm saying is we're getting
dangerously close to the point where
someone would apply force against
another member of congress now i
understand it said
don't arrest a member of congress what
about the staffers yeah
so that means you're going to here's
what you end up seeing
you're going to have marjorie taylor
green or matt gates or
lauren bobert not wearing masks saying
we refuse
and their staffers are going to be
forced to win under threat of arrest
i imagine many of them are going to say
no and so we're getting dangerously
close to that point where members of
congress
well particularly this would be the
democrats trying to exert force
over their political opposition that's
that's not going to go anywhere good
yeah and for what like for
not wearing a piece of cloth over their
faces after
almost all of them have been vaccinated
like what are we doing here
well i think that's also like they did
this big splashy thing with the arrests
and it's about something really stupid
well i i think the issue is no one has
any idea what's going on anymore
yeah this is uh a lot of people are
pointing out that part of demoralization
you guys have seen the yuri basement of
thing i'm sure we could
we get suggested it like 50 times a day
um
one of the things that happens is
there's mass media
that gives out so much contradictory
information no one has any idea what's
going on anymore
yeah and this is where we've been for a
long time so there's a really good great
example i tweeted out
the media hates you and thinks you're
stupid because
almost every single major outlet said
black lives matter does not spread
you know protests were not spreading
covet but then right-wing protests were
and now you have many on the left who
are just like protests don't spread it
but then just believe that the
right-wing ones do
and there's just every and it's elevated
beyond that right now so one of the
things we were bringing up earlier is
cdc guidance we were talking about
pregnant women and i was like the
guidance says that you can get it if
you're pregnant and then you mentioned i
guess
yeah that in april they released
guidance on a friday
saying that pregnant women should get
the vaccine and then they walked it back
on the monday
and said pregnant women could get the
vaccine like but that's a big change
right so all the women that got it
saturday and sunday who were pregnant or
like what like what did i just do
um i shouldn't could or a giant
difference
yeah now they say that they recommend it
but that
women who may be pregnant want to be
pregnant or are pregnant need to talk to
their doctors
because obviously there's very specific
and different things that could affect a
person
and everyone's got different health and
i think that applies to everybody to be
honest
the problem is it's what i was stating
earlier when it comes to these masks
when it comes to
the lockdown policies all the stuff if
you have the cdc like fauci
flip-flopping like he was yeah
what happens when a journalist writes a
story
and it's based on the information from
friday and not monday right
i mean yeah the story from friday stays
up it's not like they take it down right
it's
um but yeah the thing the things making
no sense is i think directly responsible
for
uh people not getting vaccinated i i
have an acquaintance um
a mom of three just teenage kids um you
know i think she'd be
kind of a typical person who would go
get vaccinated and she's like no because
in spring 2020 when everything stopped
making sense i stopped trusting
everything that they were saying
and so i don't want to get vaccinated
and i don't want my kids to get
vaccinated and i'm not doing that
when kamala harris and i think even joe
biden i'm not sure about
kamala yeah and a bunch of other people
came out and they were yeah and they
were they were disparaging the idea of
these vaccines
and i you know as much as the these
these twitter audi lunatics don't want
to accept it
a lot of people saw them say that and
said make sense to me
sure and then see a complete 180 and
they're probably going uh
what right but it was like as if trump
was like in the backyard of the white
house like mixing up like
you know the vaccines by himself like oh
no we're gonna need to see like evidence
like no [ __ ]
you're gonna need to see evidence you
know this is such an example of why you
sh i in my opinion you shouldn't
politicize
medical you know emergencies and and
especially why
that you shouldn't centralize a response
to a medical emergency like putting all
power in one guy's hands
doesn't make sense but but no one did it
on purpose the foundation yeah the
thing was like it was it was well i
shouldn't say that on purpose it was
that
the media wanted their anti-trump
narrative or whatever
so they were like fauci's the guy we'll
we'll we'll champion this guy
and then inadvertently the tv doctor
became the uh uh
the the end-all be-all i suppose and now
and now
you know the crazy thing is the cdc has
changed
its its opinions numerous times now what
they say is
well fauci said well it's science
science
okay okay here's the problem you
mentioned this the story from friday
stays up it doesn't go away so one day
i'm reading facebook as hypothetical
and i scroll across the story and it's
from like a day or two ago
and they say dr fauci says you gotta
wear two masks because of the droplets
and then so i read and i'm like oh okay
and then some other person
reads the story from the next day fauci
says no no there's no reason to where to
mess
this actually happened fauci was on a
show and i think it was like msnbc or
maybe cnn and they asked like
isn't
you said we should right no he didn't he
said we shouldn't like what are you
talking about i just read the news
yesterday he said we should
dude the story came out this morning he
said no you're crazy i read it in the
new york times
yeah but he's also a uniquely bad
communicator he's so
terrible at this role and so is the cdc
head rachelle wallansky they're both
horrible at conveying a message and
sticking to that message they change
their mind all the time i've written
about it again and again
where they say one thing one day and
another thing another day and sometimes
it is because it's politicized sometimes
it's because they sat down with the
teachers union and had to rewrite the
whole
messaging on schools but sometimes it's
just they don't know what they're
talking about
i saw fauci that right after
the cdc released guidance that
vaccinated people
don't have to wear masks and also
unvaccinated people didn't have to wear
masks outside
um savannah guthrie was like but what
about my kid my kid
has to wear a mask outside and thatcher
was like yeah your kid has to wear a
mask outside
but there was nothing in the cdc
guidance that said that he literally
like read it to her
and i was like but he's saying you don't
have to wear it and they both just
agreed that the kid had to wear it and
that was it
you know i noticed about fauci last year
is that he just repeats what the media
says yeah like i don't i think he
doesn't actually
right no and a lot of the guidance it's
it's this cyclical effect that
eventually spirals out of control and
just
just just bursts he'd say something like
you know he had that story whereas like
that famous interviewer says you don't
need to be walking around with a mask
because you might stop a droplet or two
and then
he changes his tune later yeah but his
tune changes like a day after the news
reports something so the news is
like a study says x y and z and then
also need to come out and say it right
but that's also the me sorry the media
never asks him what
changed he's always like the science
changed but okay what was it what
what was the study what was the study
that changed your mind where like if
kovid was too small to be contained by
the mask when you said that
did covet grow did the masks improve
actually the masks were got worse we
started wearing t-shirts over our faces
right
so you know if we had a competent media
we would get
normal answers but what we have now is
just
not that did you see the twitter video
finally came out the mashup of fouchy
you don't need a mask oh you need two
masks
your children do not need to wear masks
you definitely got to put a mask on your
child
like crazy it's like a minute long of
just contradiction contradiction
contradiction
he's the guy right this is this is who
we're relying on
yeah joe rogans had to listen to fouchy
and i was like joe no
like listen to him but you don't have to
believe and do everything he says
i think aristotle said it's a brilliant
man a sign of a brilliant man is someone
that can entertain a thought without
believing it
right yeah that's a good
that's the issue fauci has said so many
contradictory things you need
i i know a lot of people they email me
and they're like tim doctors don't know
more than most people or whatever and
i'm like dude then get a better doctor
like find the smart one yeah okay like
i'm not the smartest person in the world
i i was you know like uh there's one one
of the ingredients in the vaccine pro
was it probably glycol no no no no no
it's um
uh pro-ethylene pro-ethylene glycol i
think it's called i'm like i don't
i know what glycol is a little bit i've
read a bit about it i'm gonna go ask a
doctor about these things
because i didn't go to school and you
know there there are certain medications
that have certain adverse effects you
should look them up and you should talk
to somebody
and if you got a dumb doctor look you
can get a dumb plumber i've hired bad
carpenters
and i'm like how are these people
actually carpenters you know
so it's like that that's the main issue
that everyone that we're all dealing
with
is i think we're i was thinking about
this earlier it's uh
it's obviously information overload
because that that's that
the thing we talked about with the cdc
changing it's and updating its
guidelines
is everything literally everything yeah
so there is uh ryan long you know ryan
long comedian
he did a really great bit about this
where he was like
you know you can you can find an article
for literally
anything claiming something is racist
and he shows like articles that will
claim something is or isn't racist at
the same time like back and forth
because there's an article for literally
everything so what happens
when someone says something like i know
that
x equals one and they google it and they
find five thousand articles saying x
equals one and they're like look at all
this
then the other guy across the table says
it's x equals two and then pulls up five
thousand articles
so we're just being driven insane yeah
and it shows
yeah i don't know how we escaped i just
looked up whale hunting racists
oh yeah there are obviously it's racist
yes yeah so we got a bunch of
republicans this is this is interesting
here's a story from the hill
house gop stages mask mandate protest
nearly 40 maskless house republican
lawmakers walked across the capitol on
the senate floor to protest
of the capital physician's decision to
reinstate a mass mandate in the lower
chamber but
not in the upper chamber how does that
make sense
republicans complained the policy backed
by pelosi and other democrats
is inconsistent infringes on personal
liberty and is based on politics not
science
however the body of the 100 member
senate is less than a quarter of the
size
of the 435 member house and all about a
handful of senators are vaccinated
while dozens of house republicans have
refused to say whether they got the
vaccine okay
i heard bill de blasio he said either
you get the vaccine
or you get a negative covet test okay
but people who are vaccinated can still
transmit
right covet so what's the purpose
for having non-vaccinated people get
tested it certainly could not be to
prevent
sick people from coming to work because
the interesting thing about this
is that if you are not vaccinated you're
likely to have a more severe reaction
they say you're more likely to be
hospitalized okay
stands to reason you're more likely to
actually show symptoms
in which case you know you're sick
you'll stay home the vaccinated people
are less likely to be symptomatic or to
go to hospitals or to die
it's a good reason to get the vaccine to
be honest but again talk to your doctor
and anyway the point is why then are
they not requiring tests for the
vaccinated
we can tell better if unvaccinated
people are sick not vaccinated people
so this this policy of having people get
vaccinated and then claiming
that's the reason why you know some
people don't have to wear masks makes
literally no sense
you can still transmit with or without
that's actually the argument for why
they want the masks in which case
the senate should have to wear masks too
and negative tests are meaningless
nothing makes sense none of it makes
sense no but also the whole thing with
testing like what if you
caught covet on the way over to work
like would you wouldn't even show up in
the test yet right you'd get a negative
test you'd be
oh i'm i don't have covet you'd walk
around you'd breathe on everybody and
then
you know what would be the point of it
are they test does a test test for
antibody
response no i think that's a blood test
yeah that's the specific antibody test
yeah i think the general pcr tests are
like the swab right
uh yeah and then they put it in and the
pcr thing multiplies the
genetic material and that makes it
easier for them to spot specific things
i i don't there there's been no logical
reason
i mean look i've had a lot of
conversations with people about all of
this stuff and i'm like dude i want to
believe
that we're all going to come together
and we're going to change the world and
save everything
and you know uh we all we all pitch in
15 days slow spread all that stuff
you just got to tell me what to do and
why we're doing it yeah that's all i'm
asking
and they're like you got to wear a mask
i was like okay why and they're like
i mean slow the spread and i was like
sure
how but i heard them say we don't have
to wear masks anymore like vaccinated
well now vaccinated people need to wear
masks and like you said what changed
oh right what and i had one guy say to
me dude it's up
the science says that we have to do you
know everybody who can't get vaccinated
[ __ ] and i was like
okay what science and then he's just
like
huh i'm like dude i'm i'm not gonna sit
here
and have someone for political reasons
tell me take medication i just
i need i i'm i'm begging you i i am
begging the media
and the democrats to just answer the
questions and i know there's probably a
lot of good answers out there
and this is what brings me to the
ultimate problem i'm sure right now
there's a democrat out there
a lefty who hates me and thinks my show
is bad saying like the answer's all
right here
you don't even got to think about it the
cdc just says it and i'm like bro the
cdc said something yesterday and changed
it to it'll change it tomorrow
fauci they they just revised their their
mass guidelines proving
they were actually wrong about masks in
the first place i'm confused man
yeah and the mask didn't slow the spread
how about that like how about we never
talk about the fact that the places that
masked really heavily still had
the highest concentration of deaths and
tons of cases and
it turns out the covet is a seasonal
virus and there's very little we can do
about it
and we have to just move on what if we
just moved on
there's a vaccine there's several
there's a new one coming out soon oh wow
people have a choice to get it and if
they do they're safe
so what's the issue no like serious
question i'm not trying to be a dick i'm
just like genuinely asking
the issue is the vaccines were rushed
out you know they're still they're still
experimental that's a big part of the
issue
well i i i think they're they're
approved for emergency use
i suppose uh uh my understanding is i
have a lot of stories they've been
they've been through clinical trials
the i think it's uh it was it was fast
it was operation warp speed that's true
but i think you know there's there's two
reasons we're seeing a lot of the vares
adverse reactions
one is that we just did like 360 or
whatever 336 million doses so you're
going to see a much higher
not everybody gets the flu shot you know
what i mean so you have a huge pool of
individuals you're going to see those
percentages
and they and they've never said that
wasn't the case they've always said
there's there's adverse reactions
but i think the other issue is that when
uh so stakehomes we mentioned
stakeholders right
stakehomes posted uh about
the vaccine and trusting the experts and
like how we have to learn our
limitations and talk to our doctors and
i was like
sacoms love you bro but when i said talk
to your doctor i got attacked for it
i had people calling me an anti-vaxxer
and saying it's a waste of time
the doctor will say get it you're making
people scared and i'm like
i think one of the reasons we have so
many verse reports
is because there are people who don't go
to their doctors
and just show up to one of these like
outside of 7-eleven and sit down and
hey give me the vaccine and if they went
to their doctor the doctor could have
said like oh i noticed your history as
an ex
like maybe you should consider waiting
just a little bit maybe they still would
have recommended it and there are some
people that probably wouldn't have been
recommended it
and then we can reduce the adverse
reaction and reduce the hesitancy for
people who might be scared because
they're seeing a bunch of stuff in the
news yeah on the flip side of that i
think if the doctors had the vaccines at
this point i think more people would get
them from their doctor
not from outside of 7-eleven i think for
a lot of people it's like i don't want
to go to yankee stadium and get a shot i
want to get it from my doctor and until
my doctor has it i don't feel like this
is a real thing
that that's a really good point uh there
was a story on hannity
so hannity comes out and he's like
everybody i take the vaccine science
very seriously you know you should
consider it or whatever
there were a lot of trump supporters who
are posting things saying like you know
f hannity you know whatever mom like
trump
trump supported this like trump was a
favorite but that's a really good point
the guy who uh this guy calls uh hannity
to talk about what happened with his
doctor and media matters ends up
writing about it negatively and then a
bunch of people on the left start saying
you know hannity's
reversal was short-lived there was no
reversal the republicans have always
supported the vaccine right desantis has
always been going around doing this
but here's what happened in that story
the guy said i'm a cancer survivor
the cdc actually says on their website
talk to your doctor before
getting these vaccines if you're a
cancer survivor and so he went to his
doctor and he said he was immuno
you know the doctor says look you're
immunocompromised i would recommend
getting this vaccine because you want to
protect
yourself you know you're
immunocompromised and the man said i
then asked my doctor if you would
prescribe it
for that reason and administer it and
his doctor said no
what i don't know and i was like
well online they say you don't need a
prescription for it but you know what
i've gotten prescriptions for ibuprofen
i've gone to the doctor and they're like
i'm prescribing ibuprofen go pick it up
and so this guy said until my doctor
will prescribe it to me
as something i need because i'm a cancer
survivor and until he will administer it
i don't want to take the risk because
i'm worried about the
the underlying health conditions i have
and i'm like he's scared this is a guy
who's
who's legitimately worried about his
health and people are yelling at him
he's an anti-vaxxer they're insulting
and i'm like dude that's got to be a
scary position to be in
the cdc says warning for cancer
survivors talk to your doctor your
doctor says i'm not going to prescribe
it or administer it
not even administer it doc can't you no
right
i'd be like dude i'm worried because i
don't know who this guy is you're
telling me to go to someone else to get
it but you won't do it
that i'd be scared too and every
politician who wants restaurants or bars
to
ask people their vaccine status when
that guy comes to the door and he's like
well i don't have
i didn't get the vaccine because i can't
he has to explain it to a bouncer who
has to then make the call whether or not
he's telling the truth and whether or
not to let him in
like we want that to be happening all
over the country where people have to
explain their medical history to like
the guy at the door no your medical
history is private
there was a i saw a facebook post uh
this guy
he's like a a studio recorder musician
whatever and he was like
this should be obvious to everybody
about but i will not work with anybody
who is not vaccinated and all the
comments are people cheering
saying i won't service businesses that
don't have vaccine passports anymore
like it's
the mandatory vaccine thing is really
taking off and i responded just with i
was like what if
you know even even people who have
medical conditions that are like
advised against or have risk factors
where they they're concerned about
getting it and he was like well i mean
obviously obviously not in that
circumstance but he says i don't think
it would be a good idea to put him in a
recording booth for eight hours and i'm
like all right you know maybe that's a
good idea i mean honestly someone's
having an underlying health condition
that you know can cause them
how the facts take that stuff seriously
but what was worrying to me about that
post was the zealotry
yeah so they talk about vaccine
hesitancy and i think regular people are
are hesitant for medic
or medications for a lot of reasons you
see the opioid crisis what were they
saying in the 90s it wasn't that
addictive or something
so people are worried and they want to
get a trusted health professional to be
like here's my recommendation for you
and so now you have the opposite of that
you have vaccine zealotry
where people are just like shut up and
get it don't talk to your doctor and i'm
like that's crazy no talk to your doctor
but people are actually saying that so
when i tweeted stop listening to
celebrities
call your medical professional i got a
bunch of people on the left quote
tweeting me
saying you're scaring people for no
reason and actually people say so what
they're gonna say go get it i'm like
then what's the problem
right why are you mad that i'm telling
people to seek proper medical advice
that creeps me out i think you're right
on if okay if for instance they were
like
one percent of the people in this age
range have an adverse reaction that
doesn't mean that you have a
if you're in that danger age have a one
percent chance it means that
of all those people one percent of them
had adverse reaction but those people
might have had a specific
issue that isn't it's not random it's
not it's not
randomly affecting like there's specific
reasons why people have reactions
so you have to go to a doctor and
examine yourself before you start
injecting yourself i mean it's
you don't have to but you don't really
really should i don't i don't like
taking uh i think acetaminophen is edit
yeah like this right
here it's really bad for you regular
painkiller yeah i have bad reactions to
it
and it's like it's breaker it's like
over-the-counter blood brain barriers
ibuprofen totally fine like i you know i
get a headache i think i have a proof
and i feel great
um acetaminophen no i i i took it one
time i got really
it gave me a really bad adverse reaction
like headache migraine and i'm like i i
don't want to take the stuff anymore
now imagine if everybody said it's over
the counter it's safe
everyone used to just take it i'd be
like dude
talk to your doctor they used to sell
cocaine over the counter
those are the days right didn't they say
asbestos was safe or something i think
heroin wasn't
there heroin they still sell cigarettes
did they really they just have those ads
where it was like nine out of ten
doctors right
mountain cigarettes are right for you
somebody just posted like a ad from the
olympics like the chosen cigarettes of
olympians oh my gosh
yeah things were crazy back in the day
man i was watching old times
i was watching like old sports and like
old olympics videos and like the skill
level was so dramatically lower
yeah they really didn't care about their
clothing and like the food they ate
you know yeah bayer used to sell heroin
to children
have you ever seen that look at a bear
heroin image
it's the image of the old bottle hmm
interesting amazing baby
now they just call it you know oh they
call it like oxycodone
exactly basically the same thing i don't
know what's the difference
it's this new stuff that's freaking me
out that uh that george floyd had and
it's just fentanyl
good luck not that they're they're not
prescribing that stuff are they is that
medical figures
are they particularly they are sometimes
they prescribe fentanyl
i believe that it's relatively rare but
it's a pain controller and yes 100
people i was watching stargate
and in one of the episodes it's from you
know 2000 or whatever she's like i need
a hundred micrograms of fentanyl or
whatever and i'm like
that's a lot oh i guess doctors have
that stuff you know what i mean i want
to pull up the story though because
we're talking about republicans we got
this reporting from michael tracy
over at his uh m tracy sub stack he says
media promotes
fake vaccine hesitancy narrative to
justify coercion and scolding
this is an excellent bit of reporting
because michael tracy basically went
through this the the republicans
what their statements have been on
vaccines and he is
outright definitively proved proving the
media is lying
yeah when what but it's it's insane to
me how is it there are so many like left
personalities and democrats who
genuinely believe conservatives opposed
to vaccines
right i'm really confused he's got
donald trump he says this one produces
an overload of cognitive dissonance both
among hardcore trump supporters and
detractors
the simple fact is that trump presided
over and spearheaded operation warp
speed
the federal government's initiative to
publicly fund the production and
manufacture
of a vaccine on an expedited time scale
far beyond anything ever before
attempted in history
whether or not trump should receive
credit for doing this as an ancillary
pundit style consideration
it's just the factual reality of course
throughout 2020 trump was pilloried
by self-appointed fact-checkers the most
exalted guardians of the facts
for his assurances that a vaccine would
be available on an expedited schedule
but then that's exactly what happened
put another way if there's any single
individual
who's most directly responsible for the
historically
unprecedented mass provision of vaccines
perhaps other than the scientists who
actually created them
that individual would have to be donald
trump
this isn't something that's often
acknowledged by most of the hardcore
online factions of trump supporters
who tend to lean vaccine skeptical nor
is it acknowledged by trump's opponents
who shudder at the mere thought of
assigning him credit for anything but
it's also just true i think didn't biden
say
the vaccine was created under the
republican administration and he praised
mcconnell
for promoting the vaccine maybe you know
what's really funny
democrats are sitting there like why
won't people get the vaccines and
they're like
maybe we should just like let them know
that donald trump's the one who did it
and give credit to the republicans
really and then's like oh actually i
mean credit goes to them
here's what he says he goes on trump
himself seems cognizant of this at every
opportunity he trumpets operation warp
speed
as one of his administration's signature
accomplishments and understandably so
yeah so tracy notes that uh
trump urges all americans to get coveted
vaccine it's a safe vaccine and it works
the former president and first lady
melania trump received their vaccines
privately in january at the white house
mike pence pro-vaccine the whole time
ron desantis he said here's another odd
one
when the vaccines first became available
desantis immediately declared quote
we are working to get as much vaccine
for our citizens as possible
and implemented a distribution plan that
prioritized elderly florida residents
which resulted in a bizarre round of
media pushback
as though prioritizing the elderly for
vaccine distribution with some sinister
blocks
desantis also personally received the
vaccine and publicized this fact
when his age group first became eligible
like all other republican governors he's
been in charge of administering and
promoting his state's vaccination
program
from the outset and one of the reasons
they lifted the lockdowns was they're
like we're good
vaccines roll them out i was living in
florida when the vaccines were rolled
out i got my vaccine in florida
desantis was all over the place touting
vaccines and the idea that he
was against vaccines is like comical
it's like he both like
got the vaccines too too quickly to his
people and he also didn't want them to
take it
like how could it be both it's this is
the weirdest thing so we then i'll just
i'll just show the other name the other
names we've got
greg abbott always in favor christy
gnome mitch mcconnell ted cruz marco
rubio kevin mccarthy tom cotton josh
hawley
they have all been been been pushing
this
yet somehow the narrative is all of a
sudden republicans are coming around
right this is insane you even had the
what was it it was k ivy
where she was like the spread is the
fault of the unvaccinated literally
everybody
like in politics is pro-vaccine yeah
that
the media for some reason created this
narrative
why i mean i think because they want to
blame somebody
and they can't blame their own
factions who aren't taking the vaccine i
mean black and hispanic americans are
among the lowest percentages of
vaccinated americans
and so they can't criticize them and so
they
find the trump you know the trump lovers
and
blame it on them what's fascinating to
me is that you now have
the two most popular conservative
or right-wing candidates donald trump
and ron desantis in
in the cpac poll trump dominates they
took trump out
ron desantis dominates trump is begging
for the credit on the vaccine he's like
sending out these emails i get him and
he's like i did all this and like our
administration and the democrats won't
admit it
and ron desantis himself led the charge
and the media is trying to claim
conservatives are anti-vaxx you know
what the issue is there was one study i
saw
well briefly a lot of people noted this
or we're sharing the study
it found that vaccine hesitant
individuals that they called anti-vexers
were more knowledgeable about the data
the science and what was currently going
on
i think the simple answer is that when
people do the research
when they take a look at their medical
histories and then go talk to their
doctors
they tend to make private and personal
medical decisions for the betterment of
their lives
and it's not the result often that the
democrats want to see happen
i mean they could also solve the does
donald trump want people to take the
vaccine by having any number of
reporters who
still speak to him on a semi-regular
basis ask him do you want people to take
the vaccine i think that would just
you know get to the bottom of it pretty
quickly but they don't want to hear the
answer to that because they know he's
going to say yes they know he's going to
say
yeah of course i want you to take the
trump vaccine the greatest vaccine
that's ever been produced
i've did the vaccine with my in the
backyard
yeah trump is i don't know if uh
for those that are listening if you saw
the freedom tunes uh clip we just put
out
where it's uh uh fauci and trump are in
mount doom in the woohound wet market
and vouchers like cast it into the fire
but then trump is basically a hearing
saying i am the greatest president who
has ever lived
even fauci agrees in fact she's like no
i don't
but that's that's you know the reason
that joke works is because donald trump
if they gave him a prescott if they
wanted give the man a press conference
bring him out to the front the rose
garden one more time come on in trump
here's the microphone what do you guys
say about that it was me it was all me i
did all the work
everybody should be supporting this i
mean it's true
yeah it's is he saying everyone should
get the vaccine
yeah well i mean i just read this quote
that's dangerous rhetoric people need to
talk talk agree i agree and also for him
to say that it's the most effective
vaccine or
incred is is unknown yet but it's trumpy
you know like trump would just be like
this is the best vaccine ever because i
wasn't probably is he responsible for
this becoming politicized in the first
place
the way he talks about it i mean i
wouldn't call him responsible i'd say
the media is responsible like he should
have come out something
like i have a i have accrued a huge
group of doctors to look at this and
they're all going to take over i have a
giant panel of 60 doctors from around
the world
that are going to control this from here
on out there are a lot of things trump
could have done
that he didn't do instead he's like i'm
going to do it it's my put my name on
that thing it's like obamacare man you
ruined health care by politicizing who
was it who came out and said they should
call it the trump vaccine was that
geraldo or
i don't know if those are all somewhat
uh somebody
it was a really good idea yeah called
the trump vaccine but but i'm like why
the democrats wouldn't take
it it would have the same problem yeah
uh yes yes so the fox news story on
march 16th trump urges all americans to
get coveted vaccines
it's a safe vaccine and it works there's
no no evidence for that
he's still finding out as we go here's
the issue i i have and
like i am always criticizing the media
that that is that is the main
issue when you have 336 million doses or
whatever because we're doing a massive
rollout across the country
then you're going to end up with a
disproportionate amount of news stories
about adverse reactions
i take those stories seriously and i
want to make sure that i i will never
give someone advice
and then the last thing i want is for
someone to show up with a crutch being
like you said do this
right that's why i'm like you got to
make these decisions for yourself and
that's why it's dangerous to just like
make these demands
but i do think one of the reasons we
have so many reports in the varus system
the vaccine adverse event reporting
system is simply
the number of vaccines that have been
administered i
i think you know it's it's in the media
it's talked about a whole lot so people
are more cognizant of what's going on
and everybody's going to get it plus
like i said before
some people aren't talking to their
doctors so they're they that may be a
good portion of the
adverse events but it's just it's a
personal decision you got to make for
yourself
and you know outside of all that
i do think there's a problem with there
was a wall street journal op-ed i can't
i can't tell you about we can talk about
it in the bonus segment but youtube's
got specific rules
uh that was questioning the fda and
their decisions and so i'll just put it
that way that there are mainstream news
articles saying
we aren't doing right by people based on
you know
how to how to respond to this pandemic
which is
we'll have to save it because we'll get
banned if i get into it no joke it's a
wall street journal article but
yeah youtube's rules are so bonkers
that simply citing it is a ban worthy
offense that's that's that's the state
of this country
and i think that's a really good reason
as to why information overload
everything's mixed up and broken and we
can't figure out what's going on yeah
hard to trust really hard to trust right
now i don't think i keep saying that
this is the worst pr campaign they ever
ran like how are you supposed to
convince people to take any kind of
universal medicine
if you keep going back and forth at
every level every single person rachelle
willenski dr
fauci these are the people that we look
up to rachelle wallensky said earlier
i think it was today she was talking
about the kids who have died of coben
she literally said things that are
factually provable with the cdc's data
untrue completely untrue you know what
she said she was talking about how it's
like more dangerous than the flu
for kids and people yeah that's just i
don't know
we're like this is clearly not true well
i'm i i don't know i don't know about
that uh i do know that when crowder
said cite the cdc data he got he got
banned from youtube for it well well or
he got a suspension for bringing it up
so i don't know
i'll just say uh you know whatever
whatever walensky
says whatever fauci says it's true it's
all true it's all true yeah even if they
say something different tomorrow
so that was a really good point brought
up in um
where was this point brought up i'm
forgetting that oh yeah it was it was uh
uh was it
peter ducey or steve which one's which
one's the younger one peter
yeah he asked uh jen sackey about the
censorship and he said there's a video
from march of four saying not to wear a
mask
that's still up and you know you know
people see that he's like aren't you
concerned that you might get something
removed that later turns out to be true
for him yeah yeah she's not concerned
well but this is it's the best example i
think this last year is the best example
of the problem with censorship
and centralized control of
communications doesn't work
because that's right fauci has been
wrong on numerous occasions
and his response is but it's the science
okay i can respect that
the science changed the problem is
you banned people for what is now
the right response right you know like
you later come back and say oh those
people write the whole time then why'd
you ban them
that's where we're currently at yeah i
mean you're right that it this year was
a
a big test case for censorship but i
don't see people being outraged about it
i feel like
just americans have been so muted about
this kind of thing
it's it's really disappointing yeah it
should be across the board
outrage it shouldn't just be people on
the right i don't know how we're going
to solve whatever is going on
you got to build a new attack the media
has just shattered yeah that's why that
we're working on the fetiverse and
expanding federer's projects because you
i don't think you can
you can legislate a solution to tech
oligarchs
yeah censoring the world so we're trying
to build a decentralized network
that's uncensorable essentially yeah and
i don't think that
improving the technology is going to
make people want to be more honest like
the problem that we're looking at is
kind of like a human problem
this is a question i have about a lot of
ais who programs the ai that determines
what goes on if it's humans you're going
gonna literally have the exact same
problem you have with humans
but at least ai so it'll be different
it's special it's like it does it just
looks like a good difference look at the
self-driving car problem right so
we're trying to program cars to drive
themselves but there are some really
serious questions that we can answer
like
if you're driving in a car and the car
drives cars driving itself and an old
lady walks in front of you
does the car decide to hit the old lady
to protect the driver or swerve out of
the way to save the old lighter and ris
save the old lady and risk the driver
someone has to tell the car what to do
or i guess the funny thing is we'll be
like we'll give it an ai an artificial
intelligence it'll figure it out on its
own and the car decides to hit everybody
it's like ah whatever get them out of
the road no so somebody's got to
program those parameters you know maybe
maybe there should be like three rules
like like never harm a human and
um the second rule should be like uh uh
uh always follow the instructions of a
human and the third rules unless
it contradicts the first rule or
whatever what what are the what are the
three rules i'm forgetting them
talking about skynet no what are you
talking about i was like isn't it like
asimov's right don't become sentient oh
yeah
no thinking don't destroy us i like that
meme that's like i think you
there's the cop and he's like i think
you've had a [ __ ] too i think you've
had a bit too much to think
and he's like waking his finger at you
and it says thought police or whatever
so here's what's happened right so i
wake up in the morning and i see these
stories and they're like dc's locking
down and nevada's locking down and i'm
like i have no idea what's going
on i have no idea what the rationale is
i have no rationale i have no idea what
the data is
there's no there's no science anymore
yeah there's there's contradictory
studies across the board saying one
thing saying something else then people
are accusing one study of being
political another study being political
and i'm just sitting here like
i wonder what the chickens are up to
right like i can't
i can't i can't talk about it i can't
open on it i'm just like
everybody's gone nuts yeah the machine's
broken you know it's political madness
this is why
i i are on the side of like becoming an
artist a famous artist you look at like
rock stars and how well loved they are
like dave grohl
if we had that kind of cultural sway i
mean so much more
effective than complaining about it or
even trying to fix it politically you
can't
you can't politically fix this thing it
needs a technology didn't they do a
concert
did they do a concert where you had to
get the vaccine to come in and then one
of the members of the band who's
vaccinated
somebody involved with the organization
they didn't say who
probably in the band i don't know i see
stories like that i'm like i don't know
what this means
right if you're vaccinated and you're
putting on events for only vaccinated
people why are you shutting down because
one person was sick i thought that's
what they said was going to happen
i don't think i got to be honest i don't
think anybody knows right i think
there's a lot of people who want to
think it's a grand conspiracy because we
talk about the great reset quite a bit
and i'm like i don't know i think
they're juggling
you know there it's a bunch of people
all juggling and no one has any idea of
who's doing what or why
i think incompetence is usually the best
explanation i think we really
have a bunch of incompetent people who
have no idea what's happening
and don't want to you know give up this
moment of power for themselves and
don't want this to end right fauci is
very famous right now
more than he's on tv all the time yeah
when's that going to happen again
this is it this is well he's been on tv
before yeah he's been intense
yeah but i've never heard of him but
this is not your best you're a young
yeah he's always like 18 80 i think yeah
oh wow yeah so he's been around for
quite a long time tony you look good for
an 80 year old that's great right yeah
he gets paid you know more than the
president he's the highest paid federal
employee oh that's so messed up
not elected well look i think when it
comes to what's going on with kovid
there's a lot we'll we'll talk about
we'll we'll save it for the members
portion because we can get into some
harder numbers and we'll pull up this
wall
street journal story which i can't talk
about on youtube no joke but i can talk
about something that i think
is a a ticking time bomb and i'd love to
get your your thoughts on this carol
this is the
nationwide eviction ban is going to
expire this saturday after biden
administration loses fight
with the supreme court so uh there it is
we you know we
we're we're talking about the other day
there's millions of people
that are ready to be evicted someone
super chatted us saying that they work
at a bank and the bank is like
lining up evictions and we were like
is is there going to be an intervention
to stop the evictions because if there
isn't
we're going to have august of panic
where people are like i got 30 days
and then september 1st of 10 million
people standing in the street saying i
don't live anywhere yeah
so there are already interventions in
new york for example um
the new york state government is
partnering with an organization
to pay the landlords and that's going
to be amazing because we have you know
we just print more money
it's going to just because you're got
all the money in the world right they
weren't in a budget crisis before all
yeah
um so that's what's happening in new
york and i think that's going to happen
in other states also
um but it really also begs the question
why why like we didn't go this route
before
like if we're going to just pay all
these people like why didn't we start
doing this earlier
and and be able to evict people and so
they can move on to other homes
and pay their rent there i mean if we're
just going to be throwing money at
people like let's get started
because you know what other countries
are doing when businesses would shut
down they would keep
paying the employees the government paid
the employees to not go to work
but if they quit that business they
wouldn't get paid anymore as opposed to
incentivizing them to quit and not go
back to work which we've done in the
united states
yeah and the businesses were shut down
you know so these restaurants would have
twenty thousand dollars worth of food in
their fridges
and then they closed for even if even if
it was fifteen days all that food spoils
they couldn't sell it and now they're in
the whole twenty and they're reopening
some of them and they're like okay guys
come back to work and the people are
like no i'm getting paid to stay in
right now
dude the most brutal story was when they
reopened and then quickly shut down
so there was like there was one story
about a new york uh restaurant where
they were like
we we all our food spoiled we got rid of
it all they said we were reopening so
then we brought we ordered
you know another 20 000 of the food to
get everything back back back and
ready to go and then they announced
there was like a halt and they were
going to shut back down or something and
all the food spoils again and it is just
small businesses over that over and over
and over again is this like another
transfer of wealth to now to landlords
like descending government the landlords
are still in the hole
what are they going to pay the back rent
yeah they are bringing back
so like the story today was like one
landlord was owed 28 000 and they sent
him 24 000 but but
they're going to look into why they
didn't send the other 4 000 and then
resend it to him so yeah
yeah i don't understand how it's
happening i don't understand how there's
anywhere near enough money for it but
because then next month there's going to
be a bunch of people didn't pay this
month
and they're going to have to do it again
yeah yeah it's like we don't we really
don't learn
so you know i think
i don't think they they realized or
maybe they did maybe it's the great
reset
that you can't just stop an economy it's
a freight trip yeah
yeah what you have i think i think i use
this analogy before you see the movie
hancock with will smith
uh a part of it jason bateman's car
stops in the tracks and he can't get out
and the train's coming so hancock lands
flips his car out of the way and then
the train
hits him and he doesn't move so the
train just crumples and then every car
flies up in the air because that energy
is gonna go somewhere and then they're
all just like dropping and crashing
that's what happened so this idea that
we can just be like okay starter back up
you know turn the key and then the
economy's gonna go it's not gonna happen
right
i write about small businesses a lot um
i had a column this week about how
uh a lot of the tech firms are already
pushing back their
coming back date it was supposed to be
september which is already you know such
a long time away even now
uh but they're already moving to october
and twitter said that they're not even
opening their offices for a while no
they're close they're close yeah yeah
so there's a bunch of you know
businesses that support those big
businesses
um you know the the bodega and the halal
cart guy and the
you know the shoe shiner and the dry
cleaner and everybody on that street
and they're all paused waiting for
normalcy to return and these companies
are like
i don't know maybe we will maybe we
won't you know we'll see it's really
it's really interesting i think a lot of
younger people especially the democrat
voters because they skew younger or at
least there's more younger people they
don't understand basic economics like
a city with no industry eventually dies
out because no money is coming in
supermarkets small businesses don't
survive because they're usually
you know providing a service to an
existing infrastructure so
what happens is exactly what you said
twitter says we are closing our offices
in new york
what's below the twitter office probably
a bodega in a restaurant who are their
customers
employees of twitter we're going to
lunch now the office is closed
no names there's not even going to be
another business that comes in to
replace it so now the local corner store
has no one in the area no one's at work
so they shut down and it's going to
ripple across the board then
they pay these landlords they give
people free money they give people free
money they just keep giving free money
but you know free money is
a ticket to extract resources without
providing resources
that imbalance cannot be corrected
there's no key to just turn the engine
on to fix that
yeah to me that sounds a little bit like
they expect you to be able to travel
back in time
and just like they thought it would be
really simple to shut down the economy
it seems to me like they also think it's
going to be really simple to just
open it up again yeah just start it up
again but but so they're doing these
these emergency things in new york but
are they doing it anywhere else
i don't know um this was just announced
today in new york so
last minute save i have to imagine that
there's a lot of states that aren't
going to get these bailouts
yeah and we're going to see millions of
people without homes
i wonder at what point people just start
saying
i don't care what you say anymore you
know we're i'm already seeing
because dc locked down tons of people
tweeting they don't care what they say
they're not gonna
abide by this stuff and i'm like at a
certain point people just say enough
and i i hope you're right i just i have
seen nothing
from my fellow americans this year
especially for my fellow new yorkers to
suggest that people are going to take
any kind of stance well new york
but i mean like a year ago i thought for
sure if schools didn't open in new york
if public schools didn't open in new
york but private schools did open in new
york i was like oh the parents are gonna
riot are you kidding the private
school's open but the public school is
done
no nobody said anything yeah i feel like
uh you know we're out in the middle of
nowhere and part of me is like i was
mentioning
earlier so i'm sitting here thinking
like i wonder what the chickens are
doing you know because they don't they
don't care about this
that makes sense to me they're going
there they're eating food they lay eggs
i know what's going on
i look at the news i have no idea i'm
wondering how many people are just
going to continue to evacuate these
cities are going to keep leaving because
we've heard about the exodus
i'm wondering why you're still in new
york well we would have never left
before the pandemic i mean i knew i
lived in a super leftist place
but at least like it was a competent
city i mean it was
it was going so well that we elected
bill de blasio twice like that's how
well things were going that we just
didn't care
like who was mayor but after this year
we lived in florida for almost five
months and
it was an oasis of sanity and now we're
definitely thinking about making it a
permanent move i mean it's hard
you had your vision of your life we were
gonna live in brooklyn raise our kids
there
retire to manhattan and now it's like oh
we're gonna move to a different state
entirely
it's tough west virginia is pretty nice
i need an ocean i mean an ocean
yeah well it's not too far away it's
like it's like an hour but
uh so you know bill de blasio said the
voluntary phase is over
yeah so are you guys is is that is that
an is that a a
a factor i mean it it's not for you know
about the
vaccines like i said i'm vaccinated my
husband's vaccinated but no but it's
like the political
no yes it is it is crazy um i also just
don't believe him
that the voluntary face is over yeah
he's like he's
the biggest goof like he's just you know
and what's crazy is
he actually did a better job throughout
the pandemic than governor cuomo but
cuomo was like the hero of the pandemic
but
de blasio was actually if you if you
look at them side by side i mean they're
both
like terrible but de blasio did better
yeah yeah de blasio's probably kicking
himself for not murdering those fifteen
thousand people like cuomo did right
cause that's something cuomo got away
with certainly that was a factor i can't
i can't believe that i'm i'm yeah
i'm just i sit here every every day
every day i wake up and i'm like
murdered 15 000 people and nobody cares
he was warned
not to do it he could have put him in
the javits center or the mercy hospital
vessel and he said no i'm going to put
him in nursing homes yeah because he
didn't want to give trump the win
dead well now bill de blasio's giving
people 100 bucks
nyc to pay big apple locals 100
for first coveted vaccine injection what
this this creeps people out i'm sorry
all right you know like they did
lotteries there some people you're not
going to convince
yeah i think the hundred dollars might
get a lot of people though i agree yeah
i think people will motivate to go again
i think that the fact that they're still
at like vaccination centers not in your
doctor's office really
does deter people so if they're paying a
hundred dollars i guess they'll go stand
you know they'll go to get some random
location and get their vaccination there
but um
it is creepy it's very creepy that they
need to be handing out 100
bills are they paying people that
already got vaccinated in in retrospect
no well but what if it's dirty what if
someone goes to one of these
vaccines and says like oh i never got it
but they did because they want 100 bucks
yeah i think is there data i mean i
don't even know is there a database like
there's no
database to check whether or not yeah i
assume there would be and in the future
this would be incentive to like
say no i'm not going to get it and wait
until they start bribing for sure
right right who's going to get like the
booster for example until they give me
like a thousand dollars
you're flying a plane and they're like
we are overbooked we need volunteers
we're off like
anyone volunteer no one does we're
offering a hundred dollars right no one
does 200 300.
i i guess they you know last time i flew
it was like they can go to like a
thousand dollars
wow so you know what i what i would do
is when they would say like here's our
offer
i would go up and be like double it yeah
be like done here you go and i'd be like
all right and then i just feel like i'm
going to sit here for a few hours i'm
good
you know you should also get the food
voucher right and like a hotel voucher
you can get it
oh yeah depending on how long you get
delayed you can also be like i
i once was just like can i get first
class in the next flight and they're
like yes sir
wow and i was like yes you just gotta
they they have to get you off that plane
yeah so anyway yes people are gonna be
like oh they want boosters now let's see
let's wait it out and see how much we
can get out of this guy the less of us
that go
the faster they'll start that might not
work out
dude i i wonder if the main problem is
that there's just too many people
just in general it's poorly organized
how do you organize
millions and millions and millions of
people on the internet is
like i was just thinking about this if
we did have some sort of like debt
revolution or something where
people either refuse to pay their debts
or they default on federal reserve
um interest or whatever we would that
wouldn't be enough a chaotic revolution
would just be madness we'd have to like
create a new constitution maybe using
the manila principles
factoring in the internet using
cryptocurrency building a new economy
all at once
if there was a change we have to have
this structure in place like the
founding fathers did
we're there we're close to it the manila
principles are legit cryptocurrency is
amazing
i just think about how like a lot of our
our structures in terms of
congress and and voting was built around
a substantially smaller amount yeah less
technology like
sending like feather writing things on
with feathers and sending on horses no
ids
took two months to get messages to
england to back
right you know what always tripped me
out is like i was watching a pirates of
the caribbean
and it's like the opening scene in the
first movie where jack sparrow was on
the
boat as it's sinking and he lands and
then they're like what's your name and
he's like i'll pay you if you don't ask
why just tell him bill smith yeah
he does say smith though but like yeah
just
you can just walk and be like hi i'm i'm
you know john smith yeah
there you go prove it what are you gonna
do about it and then there's like oh no
he's been branded whatever but
yeah that's that's the that's that's one
thing people need to understand is
like i was talking about this earlier
the reason why you had to own land
in order to vote was mostly because
there were no ids
and your tie to the community was the
fact that you lived there
and they didn't want people to show up
who didn't live there vote for things
and then leave
that was part of it obviously there were
still a lot of old patriarchal
structures and things like things like
that
but there's i think the changes that
came about with universal suffrage made
sense in that
we are no it's we're not buying land
anymore
we live in new york we rent it a lot
most people are renters so
you know they vote in that capacity but
things were so dramatically different
back then
i wonder if we got to get back to uh
people got to spread out get out of
these cities
learn some personal responsibility i
don't know yeah i mean
the thing is that the cities were doing
so great until
they weren't right so it's it's like
it almost kind of shows that like the
cities have
have had their moment but um i don't
know i mean you really want people
moving out here
like well that's a good point do you
yeah yeah yeah
well i mean not too there's there's
there's pros
it's not about too close it's about like
there's there's lot sizes it's like so
you know if they
like there's a few acres around where
it's like work we have our our space we
have more space than a city
yeah what i want to live you know uh in
philadelphia we had half we had half an
acre for the whole house
so the front yard was a third the house
of third the backyard was a third and
you couldn't do a whole lot i mean we
could skate in the backyard and we had a
mini ramp
but we could only do it between certain
hours because the neighbors would be
like too late too early
now we can go out at one in the morning
and scream at the top of our lungs
and there are people who live not too
far away they don't care
some days you'll be sitting there and
you'll hear bangs you'll hear gunshots
and you're just like oh hunting again
you just turn your coffee
in brooklyn too oh yeah yeah yeah i
lived
i lived on the uh uh on um right off
myrtle and no strength
that's where that cops got assassinated
yeah i'd be the reason one of the
reasons i didn't know what happened when
it happened
so like i'm sitting in my bed i get a
text message are you near the
assassinations and i'm like what
happened it was like
one of my bosses at fusion and then i
look out the window and i see cops
everywhere
it's because i'm sitting there all day
and i hear gunshots all the time
and i'm just like sitting there pow pow
pow and i'm like dude
like you know whatever i don't know this
is welcome to new york you know what i
mean
new york's not even that bad yeah
chicago yeah
i thought la was amazing before the
pandemic i was like
as we develop electric cars we're going
to get all these gas guzzlers off the
road la is going to be a
paradise and then but i knew in the back
of my head the central electric grid and
water grid were very
very tenuous because if some sort of
cataclysm or disaster caused the water
grid to break
and the electric had to break those
people would have started cannibalizing
each it would have been
terror on earth yeah and i think coveted
was gave us kind of an early warning
sign for sure
of the danger of being packed together
in cities with a centralized
you know importing your water and your
food yeah your electricity
we could like decentralize the water
to each each house could have their own
water pump you know
electrical yeah and food grow your own
food i mean
it's pretty a drastic change right but
until then i don't see the value of
living in a city
yeah i think i think cities cause
cultural decay
at least they do now i think before
there used to be hubs of culture
because you'd live outside the city
you'd have very little contact
then you'd go into the city and you'd
see things you'd talk to people you'd
learn things and it was like that's
where the stuff was happening
you know you know my favorite movie to
cite in this regard is the movie the
patriot with mel gibson because it's a
great movie it but
there's that scene where he's like the
kids like are we going to charlestown
like we're going to town like yeah
and now it's like oh town it smells like
sour milk there's traffic everywhere
i are i i don't need to be there it's
hard to eat it's hard to sit
restaurants in new york i don't i you
know what i think back to living there
and i understood why i wanted to live
there
when i first i remember the first time i
went to new york it was just it was
doing occupy wall street
and i took a bus from virginia and i
remember
finally getting to new york city and i
can't remember i have no idea which
bridge we were crossing i can't remember
and then i see the city and the
buildings and i'm like holy
i'm from chicago and new york is five
chicagos
so i remember you you're driving
downtown you see other buildings and
it's like i'm used to that
new york was something else i'm like i
want to live here it's like being
downtown chicago
everywhere and then after a few years i
was like
you want to go to a restaurant you're
crammed in the corner in this tiny seat
with your shoulders like this and you're
like thanks for the food
there's no room so i'm exaggerating
obviously but it's like it's congested
it stinks there's nowhere to park
transportation the trains
are are often crowded and smelly and i
used to love all of this
i used to love every single thing about
it like i i really was such a new york
supremacist i like
really thought it was the greatest place
ever and i i still like you know
it's really hard it's like i can always
compare to like letting go of like a
really good relationship but like that
just isn't working out for you
um yeah i don't know if covet had never
happened
i would be here like being like new york
is the best you don't [ __ ] with new york
sorry i don't know
what was your first experience seeing
manhattan um so i i grew up in brooklyn
so um i don't really remember you know
i feel bad for you know why you you
there's a lot of people like growing up
in chicago
i got to experience the first time
seeing a city as massive as new york
but for someone who's from there there's
no point where you're going to see
something i guess you go to tokyo
right you know yeah that's crazy it's
crazy dude i had the most nutball
experience with new york city i moved to
queens i
i'd been through manhattan when i was
younger but i took the subway into
manhattan for the first time i walked
out of the subway
it looked like and it was just 90 story
skyscrapers all around me and
i could feel like the vacuum and like
yeah i was being sucked up in a way it
was
so bizarre man what a city i i do think
that tim is right sorry i have to say
this real fast i think the tim is right
and i think that cities have become too
crowded i think too many people live in
one place at one time it becomes very
insular so instead of being like a
cultural center you just get like an
echo chamber
and also when something goes wrong it
affects a thousand more people than it
would otherwise right
very much effect it's like a humble
effect and it's exponential in a city
and just this moment of conformity
um cities have really not uh been a
great place to be when everybody has to
think the same there isn't that
you know diversity of thought or just um
a lot of great culture going on because
everybody's exactly the same and you
could only be
one one way and like comedy has to be
very very
muted and all of it really just sucks
and it's
it's it is definitely a problem that is
centered on cities but it's a problem
that we're having i think all across the
country
i think one of the issues is that when
you get a complete
one-party rule there's no way to
challenge bad ideas
yeah so the people in power are like hey
we're going to lock everyone down and
shut your businesses down and you agree
because you're a democrat right
you're not a republican are you okay and
they go i'm not a republican i'm going
to wear the mask so that no one thinks
i'm a republican right
so sayeth david hogg and then you'll get
cuomo being like
i'm going to put people in nursing homes
and kill 15 000 people and then they're
like well he's a democrat so it must be
okay yeah and then they find out that he
like abused women and they all freak out
like oh no what do we do that's the one
thing we're not supposed to do then they
like didn't
and then they the freak out was very
short-lived and then they were like but
he's a democrat so it's okay
and i'm a democrat so it's okay you know
this this is why i think stakehomes is
wrong
right so uh big threat from stakeholders
i mentioned i think three times now
and uh no no but it's i think it's
important that what's interesting about
this is
it's a mainstream brand and they're
constantly these brands are trying to
one-up each other
wendy's was like always snarking and
they were more of like the youthful
exuberant like
well you suck yeah win this and people
would follow it and laugh
then stakeholders comes out and uh the
wikipedia says that they they receive
accolades for
acting like a real person on twitter
well the interesting thing is this
twitter thread that stacems put out is
a centrist view on societal collapse
and talking about what we need to do
saying that
experts need to admit when they were
wrong and apologize for it
and the other side needs to recognize
that they have limitations too and there
are experts who probably know more than
them
and i'm like thank you stakehomes for
trying
but you are late to the party joe biden
has near universal approval from
democrats
and near universal disapproval from
republicans nothing
will change this nothing nothing
you could you could you could you could
go to a biden supporter and be like i
will give you one million dollars to put
on a moga hat and they're gonna be like
no
okay maybe a million yeah a million
millions but i'm exaggerating
but i gotta be honest i uh there i i'm
willing to bet that
you know a lot of these people on the
left will not do anything to benefit
themselves if it puts them at odds with
their tribe
they're scared to break from it and it's
this it's the social order thing that
humans have where it's like you got to
be a part of
a certain tribe otherwise you'll be at
risk
yeah but the interesting thing here is
that conservatives tend to be more
individualistic
so they're less concerned about being
outed but still kind of are
like when it comes to the culture where
right there are numerous instances where
you could say something that will get a
bunch of people on the right angry with
you
and they'll start canceling you and
they'll do the exact same thing as the
left will do
that exact same i i talk about this a
lot where i i think it's
it is different like a public
conservative has a much tougher time
getting cancelled than a public leftist
i mean they came
you know recently recently i've been
clicking like hashtags like
to see like why celebrity was you know
trending and it's because they hate all
of them all the celebrities are like not
left enough like this celebrity
used to be um elena dunham uh trended
recently they hate her now she used to
be one of them and now
now she's out um i just don't see that
happening in the same way
you're right that's why i say it's the
it's the exception on the right but the
rule on the left yeah so
try there are still tribalists on the
right who will be like you can't
you know i reject this you're wrong
you're a grifter stuff
but on the left it's like jeez it's like
99 things you could say to get fired you
know get cancelled and one thing to stay
in line on the republic
on the right and with republicans and
conservatives and the intellectual dark
web kind of centrists it's 99 things you
can say without anyone caring about that
one thing you can say that'll get you
canceled
yep yeah there was a uh charlie kirk
you know was talking about simone biles
and all of a sudden i see that he's
trending there's an uproar
we brought out the other day but i think
there's a really great example philip
defranco did a segment
where he used an image of charlie kirk
with a shrunken face for his thumbnail
and i'm like why why wha phil you know
do you know phil defranco is no
he's one of the first big youtubers he
does he would do news and he's like you
know he would be like you just got
filled in and that was his bit and he
would like talk about the news
and it was always very like moderate he
actually interviewed i think he
interviewed gary johnson
during i think what was it like 20 was
it 26 16 yeah was it wasn't it
he runs every time but he was like
you know felt the time was like
libertarian calm reasonable irrational
and now he's like
he was he came out when it came when it
came to the covington kids he made a
video where he was wrong
then when it came that there's other
instances but now it's like charlie kirk
says something that people think is
stupid and i'm like
who cares whatever like i don't charlie
kirk would say whatever he wants
it's got no bearing on the olympics some
guy had an opinion great
and then i criticized phil because he
tweeted like you're you know whatever
and was insulting
him but then i saw today he was like
we're back and it's it's a thumbnail
and not only is he talking about charlie
kirk which is fine but he
he does this meme where they shrink
charlie kirk's face which i i'll admit
great meme it's really funny like the
the joke is that every time charlie
makes a point his face shrinks or
something
memes are great you know by all means
make fun of him and ben and everybody
else and me and you know who
i don't care but like why would someone
who is known for being a like
straight shooter news personality all of
a sudden be playing tribal politics
and just insulting someone for content
this is cultural decay
yeah when you can see it's infecting
everything the new york times has become
this
our mainstream news apparatus has
completely become crap all over people
and find whatever reason to hate
somebody for tribal points
and then even now i mean youtube is
built on this basically
drama channels and here you go this is
it our entire news media is now
just who can i crap on for clicks yeah
strife
sells i mean that's like it's popular i
i i find myself like sometimes clicking
on a headline of like two celebrities
i've never even heard of
to be like this celebrity and this
celebrity are like beefing and like oh
what are they fighting about like what
happened
like i don't even know them i don't even
know who they are i'll do that and then
i'll like i'll
i'll see it i'll be like ah no i'll
click that i'll x out really fast
i hope the algorithm didn't catch that
but it did of course yeah it knows i
clicked
i i apparently you know people were
commenting the other day that some
leftist channel like made a video about
me like an expose and i'm like do this
like the 80th expose who cares
i just ignore all this stuff and then
there's like you know people messaging
me right now because there's another hit
piece coming and it's a big one i guess
and i'm like
i literally don't care like i just i'm
not gonna make videos about this stuff
i don't i don't care about myself enough
to engage in
in you know interpersonal conflict on
youtube or to be
like you know oh charlie kirk said this
now like aoc
she's in congress with 12 million or
whatever followers and she's extremely
prominent and influential she's a
politician
uh ceos politicians and to an extent
many personalities i think it's
it's it's fair game but when it's like
people just doing drama to bicker with
each other news outlets being like we're
gonna write garbage fake trash to like
try and get somebody i'm like
you know what there's a rock i can crawl
under and just you know dig a hole and
play video games the rest of my life
that was interesting you said how that
you could get a biden supporter put on a
mega hat if you paid them a million
bucks
and well i was i was being happy you
couldn't but but
you're kind of right that if you bribe
people they will change their political
ideology and the problem is biden has
his finger on the
money printer mm-hmm so he's bribing
everyone right now
yeah are they unloading you know to
i i don't think uh maybe a million
dollars would get
a biden voter to put on a magazine 50.
you could probably get tons of
biden supporters to put on my house for
50 bucks they don't have loyalty to that
guy
no no it's but they they they are scared
of looking like republicans maybe
yeah you get that picture circulated you
lose everything they think it's a clan
hat like they'll they'll be like no way
dude yeah it's like
tell them this put their hat on i'll
take a picture of it and i'll give you
fifty thousand dollars they'd probably
say
no and i'm not kidding maybe that's a
good idea for a man in the street you
know video we'll go to
we'll go to new york and be like how do
you feel about trump no 50 is still too
much
i think you have to go for 50 bucks like
50 bucks is sort of like it's a one
second thing like
just see how little people really care
yeah yeah 50 000
i mean you know i put on like i can't i
don't even know what i put off yeah
obviously there's regular people who
voted who don't really care all that
much
but i mean like look at look at what
david hogg said about wearing masks
where he's like
i'm gonna keep going because i don't
want people to think i'm a republican
it's like wow what
i live in like the super leftist area
where i mean masks were absolutely
like you know a signal that i belong i'm
part of this group
if you're not wearing one you're not
part of the group and it's important to
people to be part of the group so
you know yeah maybe fifty thousand
dollars a lot of money it's too much
it's so much
you gotta like do like a hundred bucks
like this here's a hundred dollars like
they say
put on this hat no they would they i
think you'd get a lot of tickets yeah
really
well they'd put it on maybe like yeah on
camera we're filming right
yeah i think i think 100 bucks would do
it wow i mean people
people are about to get the shots but
they've like deferred for like so long
like
the shot you know the vaccines have been
out for like months and months but now
they're gonna get it for the hundred
bucks
but what i mean is like when you look at
those polled who are democrats yeah and
they're 90
approval for joe biden those are the
kind of people i think would be like
never
right regular people on the street right
on the street would do it yeah of course
of course of course
i mean like the partisans yeah my
neighborhood would be tough
park slope would be because they're also
rich
i'll give you i'll give you a hundred
dollars to wear the maga hat and we're
gonna film you
i got a feeling they're gonna say no
yeah no it would have to be like regular
people on the street
how about a college campus that's really
because they want the money hard boy
would they get in trouble if that photo
goes around
what are they gonna say they paid me to
wear it they'll be like what you took
money to wear that thing
you're nazi i do think i do think money
talks
yeah i'm willing to bet that you could
find like a moderate
left or right personality offer them
enough money and they'll flip sides
instead
it's the whole you know you offer enough
money and people will do it but
i think i think 50 000 everybody does it
like
yeah ten ten thousand everybody does
that i think so
no i don't know about i don't know about
everybody i think everybody a photo of
you wearing that hat
you will never get hired in your city
your your friends will be like what is
this
and you'll try claiming but they paid me
to do it yeah they paid me a lot of
money to do it
you took money to support donald trump
how dare you i mean look you see what
some people get canceled for
i'm not convinced people on the street
would do a lot for a klondike bar you
know what i mean so sure yeah you could
just offer just the klondike wire
what would that that that's we should
actually get money you know i i want to
do this
melting class i want to go out on the
street
and i want to go to you know what would
be funny we're in an area that's very
trumpy
i'll go in there and ask people to wear
a biden hat it's like how much for you
to wear this buying hat take a picture
of you you don't you know what happened
every single conservative would be like
how much money yeah whatever right you
know why
multi klondike well i know it's like a
guy
you find a guy with a maga hat and you
say bro i got 50 bucks for you to wear
this biden hat he'll be like
put it on and be like are we good all
right thanks have a nice day because
they don't care
no one's going to come after them for
wearing a biden hat right yep trumpet on
the other hand
right because you know there's
acceptable opinions and there's
unacceptable opinions it would be
hilarious when
like the trump supporter is like his
friend walks up and he's like i just saw
a picture of you in a biden
and he's gonna be like they gave me 50
bucks let's go get some beers
no one will care no i don't care in fact
uh interestingly there's a phenomenon
where urban centers even in red states
are very
pro-democrat very critical race theory
and all that stuff that's the craziest
thing to me
yeah it is really crazy like to hear
that about that in like tulsa
and other places yeah yeah yeah even in
west virginia
you'll we'll drive through some areas
and we'll see like the the new pride
flags and stuff like that and i'm like
wow in west virginia huh but not
everybody you still
if you go to urban areas you tend to see
it but west virginia is like
the second most trump supporting state
yeah
so they are all guy you got crazy things
to say about a lot of crazy things
believe it yeah i'm sometimes like i
would not want to have a conversation
you know but there are a lot of where we
are there's a lot of rich
democrat people from dc who move out
here because freedom
right people like the freedom that's
what happens
nobody wants to live in dc there's mask
mandates right nobody wants to live in
maryland they're very restrictive and
for a while restrictions as well
now they can drive about an hour and a
half be in west virginia
there's a funny thing because in the
area where i actually live
they say that they can all tell who the
dc transplants are
because they'll be like someone left
their garbage at raccoons came and
they'll be like
yeah they're like welcome to the
mountain and they're like there was a
bear the other day and they're like oh
how many just one
then there's like gunshots going off and
then people are posting online like why
are there gunshots and they'll complain
and will come out and be like you know
i'm wondering why it's happening and
they're like
people shoot all the time yeah there's
like a range right down the mountain
like
right down the road what do you expect
there it's crazy there are people who
live within like a few minutes of
walking
there's like an open range in the
mountain and there's like a house right
there
there's a bunch of houses and you just
like walk for about 10 minutes and then
you're at a shooting range and people
just live right there shooting every day
non-stop and there's hunting
yeah yeah so these these urban liberals
you don't want to stay away
man because it's a bunch of gun right
wings of guns and bears
and bears records we really need to
spread out
it's so important i kept thinking when i
was like a kid
like 10 12 years ago oh we'll just build
magnetic trains from small village to
small village and re-renegotiate our
our infrastructure we'll have instead of
big cities we'll have lots of little
ones all interconnected
where's the magnetic trains guys what
about like cities that are concentric
circles run by supercomputers
all right that sounds like burning man
minus the computer i guess yeah we we um
we don't we don't uh uh have a
collective cultural mission
it's so weird like maybe because our
technology's been suppressed
for so long by like the electric grid
they want to keep those copper wires
pumping electricity and making their
money off of their copper pipes and we
have no competition bro that's the
problem the copper industry
we went to the moon because we were like
russia what up soviet union
we're gonna go to the moon so the u.s
had been losing
every element of the space race sputnik
launched first they put a dog in space
and the u.s was like
every step of the way we're behind let's
go big
yeah and so i think like the only thing
the us actually won was getting to the
moon because they were like well we
can't win all of these things let's just
so they rallied everybody they made it
the mission everybody was cheering they
were like
yeah and at the same time there was
still a bunch of crazy stuff going on
outside of that you know
i protest conflict trump was giving a
speech and he said that we'll be the
first country to put a man on mars
and i didn't believe him it was like it
just i just heard it and i was like
you blow hard like you know prove it
prove it
i don't believe you anymore i i'm and i
know that the corporations
are more effective at getting people
into space than the american government
mm-hmm
if you look at the last year of activity
so i i just have to go to mars it's
what's the mission called we're going to
build a colony on
the moon first and then from the moon we
launch to go to mars project artemis
yeah artemis there you go well you want
to know why it's never going to happen
ian what going to mars yeah i'm going to
blame the media do it check out this
check out the story
new npr ethics policy it's okay for
journalists to demonstrate
sometimes you know why i think i'm
willing to bet they changed that
headline
they say npr rolled out a substantial
update to its ethics policies earlier
this month
expressly stating that journalists may
participate in activities that advocate
for the freedom and dignity of human
beings
on both social media and real life the
new the new policy eliminates the
blanket prohibition from participating
in marches rallies and public events
as well as vague language that directed
npr journalists to avoid personally
advocating for controversial or
polarizing issues
this policy will change the moment an
npr employee comes out with a gadsden
flag preaching to end the lockdowns
they're going to be like not that
freedom and dignity that's
fascism that's the thing i think every
every activist thinks that they're
involved in the pursuit of freedom and
dignity i think npr really hasn't
thought this one through
because the you know the first even like
and
even a pro-cuban activist uh i i can't
see npr being okay with that that's a
good point
yeah well they say that the new policy
reads npr editorial staff may express
support for democratic civic values
that are core to npr's work such as but
not limited
to the freedom and dignity of human
beings the rights of a free and
independent press
the right to thrive in society without
facing discrimination on the basis of
race ethnicity gender
sexual identity disability or religion
what was the first one
the first one was the rights of uh i'm
sorry
the freedom and dignity of human beings
including unborn human beings
oh no of course the rights of free and
independent press
so you can protest in support of
infowars oh yeah alex jones
yeah yeah is it okay to march in a
demonstration and say black lives matter
what about a pride parade in theory the
answer today is yes but in practice
npr journalists will have to discuss
specific decisions with their bosses
who in turn will have to ask a lot of
questions the carved out is somewhat
narrow
protests organized with the purpose of
demanding equal and fair treatment of
people are now permitted
as long as the journalist asking is not
covering that event however rallies
organized to support a specific piece of
legislation would be off limits
other events featuring a slate of
political candidates from one party are
also out of bounds from one party
are we saying that there were no npr
reporters at like
the pink hat march in 2016 like come
on yeah lots of them actually in fact
i know a lot of npr people are activists
like they're they're all activists new
york the whole media apparatus in new
york new york's a different country at
this point
i don't even know what's going on in new
york their the media ecosystem in new
york is
insane yeah you're you're on an island
yeah new york post you guys are
yeah they censor you they block your
stories yes
and then like it's it's really cabally
that you're familiar with the journal
lists of course so for those that aren't
familiar
new york journalists had this and they
probably still do lists of where
uh message boards basically where they
all communicate and share stories and
all believe the same things
and it's basically like there's no
competition in media
because all the news outlets are in the
same place right even fox news but the
joke with journalists is like they were
sharing opinions and like people were
like
journalists have opinions like come on
like why don't we just be honest about
it like why doesn't everybody just speak
their bias and like get it over with we
all know
that everybody's biased like it's
there's no such thing as somebody who
like
has no predisposed opinions like just
get it out there
yeah but maybe this whole thing is over
with like you know yes
like journalism being no opinions to be
a public figure
and your goal is just to report but then
to use that position to assert
that's where the problem arises if
you're just trying to be a journalist
and i i think you're right maybe it's
just over
it's over about it yeah it's it's it's
propagandistic warfare at this point
right that's it yeah i mean i saw um
somebody yesterday um i shared a tweet
and they were quoting nbc news but
because the guy i shared it from
um it was robbie's star starbucks yeah
so somebody was like
i can't take you seriously when you
share robbie starbuck but he was like
literally
just quoting nbc news he had clipped the
article but it was like no
i can't i cannot even cannot use his
copy and paste i cannot have his uh
you know fingerprints on this and it's
just
it's so tribal that we like can't even
believe a news source when somebody
we don't like shares it yeah we're we're
at a point where
the hyper polarization is so intense i
don't think the news is relevant anymore
people will scan the news and be like
don't care if that's true don't care if
that's true
this one kind of screws me if it's true
so i'll ignore it and this one
perfect let me tweet that yeah that's it
and then i don't know where we end up my
my thing is get out of the cities you
know
don't sit around they're taking they're
they're taking time bombs
they're going to lock down everything
again miami's doing well yeah that's
true a really good mayor
yep yeah miami is doing well florida in
general texas so maybe
maybe it's um if you live in a blue
state stay there yeah there you go you
know
don't come out here npr's private
company yeah they call it public radio
but it's
funded by private money two percent of
their revenue comes from uh
public grants from i think the
department of commerce and the
department of education we actually
pulled this up before the show
a lot of people keep saying it's my tax
dollar it's like a little bit i guess
but you know sure it is your tax dollars
to a certain degree yeah npr is uh uh
you know a lefty progressive media
outlet
jimmy dore was telling joe rogan about
this when he was on a show and i was
thinking
yeah joe actually said well they should
have to change their name
yeah i was just about to say that it's
not public radio right and like the
federal express
had to change it it's not federal the
federal reserve is not federal
they had to change it to fedex yeah i
don't know if they had to but they did
in like the 90s it used to be called
federal express it still is federal
express
it's fedex now according to yeah they
officially changed it yeah
i think it's i think that is that you
could call it public or federal
right it is not federal wow i didn't
know that yeah
i don't know if they did to avoid a
lawsuit or what but i'm glad they did
even the word fed is a little misleading
yeah
why did they change their name
somebody told me that every time a
company changed their name like dairy
queen changed her name to dq and kfc
yeah kfc right there's a reason they do
it there's always a reason the kentucky
fried chicken they they didn't actually
have enough chicken right oh really i
thought it was because fried chicken
like you know it was like health
consciousness had like
increased yeah i'm not sure about that
fried chicken was out maybe that's more
i don't think they were forced to change
their name from federal yeah i don't
think that i don't remember it ever
being forced
i just said it happened like in the 90s
or something fact check yeah it was
2 000 they rebranded everything to
federal to fedex
and all the planes and everything was
changed yeah maybe it was i don't know
i would like to see that put into law
that you can't call your company federal
or
because i was like could i make a
company called like federal national
broadcast corporation and like sell
t-shirts you can't
i don't know if i can is that legal it
shouldn't be legal didn't the postal
service sue
the band the postal service oh i don't
know oh yeah that's
yeah that's ridiculous because they're
they're entities who have branding and
names and stuff like that
that may have happened i'm not sure the
postal service is a big deal they
thought
ben franklin was like the first
postmaster general and that was a
national
company now we have ups we have
basically amazon is like our our
national shipping agency right now and
it's a corporation like we
really need a national a national
shipping
like organization i don't know about a
post office
yeah yeah but we need more of those but
i don't like the government having
monopoly on that stuff either can we go
to the market
go to mars already can we just can can
joe biden come out and be like
i'm going to scrap everything in the
budget bill and we're just going to
spend it on mars
i'd be like all right there we go i'm
down let's print that money i'm i'm
bored somebody slips that idea to him
right before he goes on and you have a
good shot of it
you know what can we sneak index cards
to biden yeah you know so it's like he's
handed the cards
like we do this ocean's 11 style thing
where the cards get switched and then
he's like
we're gonna go go to mars
yeah that's it i'm done yeah good you
could probably pull it off
i'd be like i don't care about the
culture or stuff you would do it they're
saying the same thing yesterday they're
saying today it's just getting noisier
and noisier and more confusing and let's
just go to mars
that's just we'll just go let's do it
you know we'll send we'll send a bunch
of supplies first
do we know what goals is that is that
the best option right now
no they're magnetic mars doesn't have
the mass to sustain life in any
meaningful way
unless we build like bases and the issue
is that we'd have to build
a massive we have we have we'd have to
be able to build and we'd be able to
refine fuels
and build rockets to get off the planet
in the first place so it's like mostly a
one-way trip but then
you'd have to live in in bunkers forever
because of radiation and because of
there's no atmosphere and there's no
magnetosphere to protect from the
maybe we should consider this whole yeah
like let's do some other stuff first
all right all right here's my other day
let's find an earth-like exoplanet yes
and just go for it yeah all right that's
it i mean that sounds better than you're
you know living yeah it's going to take
it'll take too long
can we build a stargate or something
yeah can we find one probably
a good show sure yeah i think you could
super accelerate through
um black holes through those what are
they called charged black holes
they have a double event horizon i think
you can super accelerate through them to
another star
you want to know the sad reality if
there is life out there that travels the
stars
and they have massive ships that can
travel faster than light and all that
stuff
we are but humble chickens on the earth
indeed they look at us
like like nothing you know not even i'm
thinking about like when i watch the
chickens go do their chicken business
and they're like walking around making
little weird noises and they went into
our garden bed where we have the basil
and they started digging because they
like to do these dirt baths and they
uprooted the basil and i'm like so we
got to repot them but you look at them
doing that and we laugh like look at
them they're so dumb they're rolling
around in dirt and then i'm imagining
like i'm sitting here like
working on the computer and like reading
up stories and imagining like some
interstellar ultra intelligent species
being like look at them they're like
trying to read information but they go
so slow they can barely understand
what's going on in their own world eyes
did you see the the meme that was like
what if ufos are just other
uh planet brilliant planets millionaires
they probably are
yeah they probably wouldn't be i mean
it's not going to be the
the well i don't know it's assuming
there's wealth and that kind of stuff on
other planets
yeah you know we we have we can barely
leave our own planet
yeah it's like we go to the moon 70
whatever you're 60 something years ago
and we're like yay we
we went from the blue one to the little
one and that's as far as we've gone but
i mean nobody else has gone there's only
one flag on the moon
i mean at least we're still number one
you know it's true yeah for now
like we're not that great compared to
ben but we're still better than
everybody else
yeah we need to i don't know we need
like how do we how do we have that big
scientific breakthrough
yeah you know rocketry was amazing how
do we get that anti-grav man how do we
get that uh
uh you know faster than light travel oh
maybe it's not possible maybe we're
trapped here
it's possible we need to mathematically
prove it first that's why einstein's
equals mc square was so revolutionary
because
he simplified the mathematics that
showed the i don't know what
what is that the speed of light equals
energy gas
energy equals the mass times velocity
yeah the mass
squared times the speed of light um and
he basically i don't know created like a
density of energy or something
um but he made it he did it simply so if
we can
show that you can get more energy out of
a system than you put into it like for
150 years they've been
quoting these these ancient laws like
newton laws that are like say you can't
get more energy out of a system than you
put in
see that's how how you get water out of
wells and they're like using these old
theories
but if we can rewrite physics
mathematically then people
will accept it then the technology will
start to become exciting you know
you know be cool i don't think we're
around for any of that but
yeah what if like one day some dude's
just chilling
and then he accidentally like sneezes
and farts at the same time and it pulls
up the console commands
and then he's like he sees this like you
know you know the what
what is that little thing called the
indicator when it's blinking on the
screen whatever and then he's like
uh and then uh appears and he's like
search
item list one through 100 and then i'll
send a bunch of words
and then it just starts like
manipulating you know you know console
commands are right video games
and then he's just like whoa and then
he's like set player size one thousand
he's like
he's like and then all of a sudden we
see some dude just destroying reality
with console commands
i'd actually welcome that i'd be like
hey at least something's happening i
guess
you know because other than that it's
just same old thing every single day
with the insanity and the absurdity and
no one does anything
like we get the republicans being like
we refuse to wear masks and i'm like oh
we did this last year
yeah like here we go again it's crazy
that this is like we have the internet
and it's so amazing and
like we should be so wowed by it every
day and we use it to argue with like
doofuses on twitter
at least i do for sure i restrained
myself
so hard such a time so i'm gonna tie
even to you and chris i can't i can't
bring myself to talk to you guys on
twitter
i just can't oh you saw that tweet yeah
it was just text we were talking about
censorship ian thinks that piracy isn't
theft
and my brother got mad because he made
uh a video
that went viral and was pirated over a
billion times
literally a billion times and his face
isn't in the video
so when it got pirated he got no credit
for it and in fact it took the money
away from his actual
revenue source which was the video on
his youtube channel and that then he
started trying to go after people like
who are stealing it they're putting in
tv shows or whatever
a billion views it's crazy that's a lot
of money yeah and he got
zero for it because it was stolen and
the funny thing is the video is like
years and years old
you may have seen it it is a van and
then it says actual police footage
and a hand reaches out it's being pulled
over by a cop you know you hear the
police chatter
and then there's a baggie attached to
balloons and he releases the balloons
and it says how to ditch your stash
and then the cop runs out so it's firing
it here so it's really fake
but because his his face isn't in the
video he gets no credit for it
what do you do watermark videos and
stuff it's impossible
so if you the assumption that you had
ian was that someone's going to earn
recognition because it's a picture of
their face
and their name but a lot of people
produce music with no words
so there's no singing it's just a song
like i oh and then they just download it
and then they don't know who made it or
where it came from and it goes viral and
then
the people who made it really good
example who is that guy
um rusty cage he has that the the knife
song
um he he he did a video where he took a
knife and he was doing the knife game
with your fingers
and he sang he's like i forgot how the
song goes
and then what happened was some rapper
used that line
and then on tic tac the song went crazy
viral
with for someone else who had basically
taken what he had written on tick-tock
yeah it went viral because uh someone
took the song and then remade it
the melody and everything but put it in
their own song and then he didn't get
any credit for it it was just basically
taken from him
and then the other guy gets to go viral
for it so yeah that's the problem of
i mean i guess that's just general
copyright infringement yeah but the
piracy was people taking my brother's
videos and then re-uploading it all
across their own channels and just
publishing it and sharing it whenever
they want with it
yeah i don't like when people um what do
you call it
impersonate like take credit for your
work i don't like that
that's bad actually very bad but what
about if
you write a song and then everyone
starts downloading it and they don't
know who wrote it or where it came from
that's a problem
yeah that's the problem with you got to
be able to help someone trying to run it
yeah so the funny thing is the reason
chris got mad about that is
he dedicated a lot of time and energy he
got a car they got props they bought all
this stuff they produced it
he got nothing for it and now he and
then he was eventually like we i can't
afford to do this anymore mm-hmm
we should play the video someday we do
credit
we spent money to make this video we it
was taken like the success of the video
was robbed from us
and we just generally lost money so now
there's no more videos
otherwise that could have been way more
rectify chris bloomberg time for super
chats it is time for super if you
haven't already give us a like
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel go to timcast.com because the
bonus segment is where we're going to
talk about
the forbidden wall street journal
article because youtube is
creepy and we'll uh we'll respect
youtube's rules and keep it to our own
website
but uh share the video share the show if
you like it and get those super chats in
let's read what y'all have to say
all right dabob says
thanks all for your hard work for your
work gave mom a true crime subscription
for mom's
mom's day might sign up might sign her
up for tim cast so you can red pill her
fundraising to fight ex-wife for custody
can explain
and pay friend hand robert at what
okay i don't know what that is um we are
in the next week or so gonna be
launching
the new show which is like
i don't know the right it's tales of
interest we'll call it that tales of
interest there there are spooky stories
there's unexplained mysteries there's
creepy science experiments
it's just like the dark underbelly of
the world that's what we're going for
with it
so we're working on the design the
branding we got a cool team and the
articles are fantastic
go to timcast.com check out the articles
from shane he just put one up
about the simulation theory he's got one
about birds disappearing so he's you
know writing these stories and they're
incredible stories
and then we're going to actually make a
like a podcast show with sound effects
and then it's we're gonna have the
members version as us talking about
these crazy things so like
simulation theory dmt all that you know
true crime
that stuff you can find a lot of shane's
earlier work i think it's under the name
of cassandra
his early stuff isn't that no no that's
awesome oh it is so if you search shane
you'll find
oh it no it might have been published
because uh it because he didn't have a
violin no i think it's all shane but he
i thought he didn't have an account for
a while so some of it was coming through
on cassandra
i i think that's probably obvious by now
okay and we're going to be creating
like its own dedicated you know channel
page so when you click the channel
you'll see all the articles
and then we're going to put the videos
and it's going to be a blast goat man
jack says if ian doesn't dress up as a
pirate for halloween
yeah i will be most disappointed that's
right that's a good idea
all right audra lin says hey tim my
brother duck
was just promoted to the rank of master
sergeant in the usaf
could you and the crew please
congratulate him for his hard-earned
achievement thanks
that's awesome congrats congrats duck
and
um if you make colonel let me know if
they let you into the stargate program
because i'd love to see you
sure neil and carter up to these i'm
just kidding flimsy fox says hey tim as
you might be able to tell my
profile picture i am a furry i want to
expand my influence in the community
however it's completely taken over by
authoritarians how do i navigate this
i honestly have no idea how to navigate
the furry community
unfortunately very authoritarian
authority
yeah there's actually like there's like
some articles about like furry nazis or
something
is that real what is happening that's an
old one though so i don't even know
what a simulation marble 755 says the
country is so split
perhaps another catastroph catastrophic
event needs to happen
like how the us came together during the
events of world war ii with pearl harbor
some say january 6 was that event
definitely not that divides the country
severely
but i believe it was the project for a
new american century who claimed that we
need a new new pearl harbor and it's a
horrifying statement
in my opinion but also 911 and it didn't
last it was like brief
are coming together yeah we ended up
doing bad things the internet kind of
blew the
weapons of mass destruction thing out of
the water and tainted that whole
unification yeah
all right fox die says or foxd
thank you for your great service tim i
really think you should consider talking
to ed snowden he's an innovator in the
free speech
press movement and would educate you
from his pov how government sees control
yeah that'd be great i guess the one
challenge is we never do remotes we're
actually not
built for it maybe when we do the new
studio we might actually new studio
we might actually accommodate that but i
still very much want people to be in
studio it's
infinitely better when you have someone
in front of you but maybe we'll actually
we actually don't have any of the
infrastructure built to do any kind of
remote conversation because we didn't
want to we specifically were like nah we
don't want to do that so
all right let's see butters oregano says
ian i'm glad you're feeling better
digital piracy is theft and your denial
of this leaves me speechless
like michael knowles recently released
book speechless controlling words
controlling rights
someone told me that them calling it
piracy enables the fbi to go after
people with like piracy laws
old old piracy laws mark and reprisal i
really like
hardcore pirate like so i'm not i didn't
follow up
on that but if that's the case that's
that's terrifying
because real pirates go around and steal
loot and kill people so that's not what
copying information is all right let's
see
heathen says tim i'm off topic but when
are you going to start harvesting the
deer eating your apples they are
delicious
i don't know if we're allowed to kill
the deer i don't know there's rules
someone told me that if they're on your
property and they're coming right for
you
you can self-defense i was told turkeys
are fair game but deer might be
different
so the there's a couple babies there's
four that come here all the time there's
one i think might be a younger dude i'm
not sure
but there's a mom with her two babies
and they come in and they
mill about but they don't like we got
the mineral blocks they don't want them
huh deer walked right up sniffed it
sniffed it again walked away and i was
like but it's it's apple scented
look it's going down i guess they didn't
want it
yeah spoiled deer yep i wonder where
they're going getting good stuff
scott james pilkington says jaffa cree
tim cast crew and greetings from new
zealand i just want to say thanks for
all the awesome work you guys are doing
and there's a survivor survival book lot
on humble bundle at the moment
that looks to be good value peace and uh
for those that aren't familiar jaffa
creates a stargate reference
it was funny when i was doing all the
star trek references it was like all the
star trek stuff and then someone was
like tim watch target and i was like
okay and now it's all started references
hey shout out to humblebundle.com i've
been using it for about
seven years every month you know you can
spend like 10 bucks a month or 12 bucks
a month and get like 12 free video games
or spend a dollar on
packaging at five games it's amazing
that's awesome
old man new to trading says hey tim
bannon is right in regards to schools
i just got an email regarding vaccines
and masks charles county maryland
yeah all these schools are going to be
like are going to be sending out these
messages to parents who are going to be
like
i need my kids in school yeah and
they're going to they're going to be
like no
and they're going to lose it i hope
you're right me too
well i don't know possibly we didn't
lose it last summer is the issue here
yeah it's been longer yeah i don't know
i just thought by last summer
when schools wouldn't open parents would
like you know
lose it but they didn't all right
so i see a couple people saying uh
saying this believe kaiser says someone
in albania leaked pfizer's contract and
it's crazy
i will have to look into that william
carlos says tim you should reprint some
old articles from the 90s and 2000s
so the new generations can see who these
career politicians really are
also please check out the pitch from uh
i won't read your email but we'll look
into it
yeah yeah well just pulling up all joe
biden videos is effective
danny douglas says u.s navy just
restarted the full mask mandates i
almost put my fist through a wall got
basically forced into the vaccine to be
able to work without the mask
can't get out until i finished my
contract in 2024
yeah they they told everybody you know
they were like oh it's is this what you
got to do
desantis said get the vaccine we're back
open and then he opened up he kept his
promise
he did yeah all right lippool of death
gaming says as a cancer survivor i
cannot get the vaccine
as the peg component uh as as the peg
component i've had it before
and it resulted in hospitalization for a
month and pancreatitis
there you go cool so yeah hopefully
they're going to have legitimate medical
exemptions that are a little bit more
broad i guess not perfect but
to your doctor all right let's see
hey uh what is this um you know what i
don't know what that is that
someone's mentioning an ailment their
their family has i can't i don't know
what that is so i'm gonna avoid it
because
i don't know what to say i can't yeah uh
let's see
paranormal underground says eric finnen
recently agreed on twitter to debate the
huntsman
a senior fellow at security studies
group and china supply chain expert
on the freedom phone get huntsman on
please interesting
we'll take a look so jason d says
ibuprofen is acetaminophen
also there was a festival for asbestos
back in the day
where they a they they a wicker man out
of asbestos to show off they made one
oh wow i'm firing through probably is
ibuprofen acetaminophen i'm looking that
up i do not believe that
yeah i don't think that's true i think
ibuprofen is ibuprofen and acetaminophen
is acetaminophen because acetaminophen
has
operates under a brand name and there's
a different brand name for ibuprofen
they're not the same yeah they are not
the same yeah yeah sorry
i will not say those those uh brand
names
all right let's see what we got oh man
yeah maybe we should save this one for
the
yeah that's a little too spicy yeah dr
sir mister says on twitter a journalist
named floorgill
said someone needs to create adult
content
for children oh yeah i saw that what
yikes yeah
can you repeat that i was reading the
ingredients i don't i don't know if we
can repeat that okay
and then she deleted it and was like i
didn't mean that i didn't mean it oh no
and it was like hear me out
[Music]
dude crazy conversation man dude yeah
here we go ginger brown says nova vac
still to come in fall winter and could
provide a solution for a lot of people
who remain unvaccinated
no mrna components no dna components no
spike proteins
90 for 90 efficacy and mild side effects
so far
yeah i think johnson johnson is not mrna
right right this is the crazy thing when
people say like
um you know they don't want the mrna
vaccine i'm like johnson johnson yeah
and it's it's still available isn't it
yeah yeah
i don't know man ultimately i'm just
like i don't want to be
either convincing or like unconvincing
right what i mean
yeah because you're not a doctor talk to
your doctor i don't want people to be
like i didn't get it it's your fault
like
don't don't come to me for advice like
that's why i say about you know when joe
gave advice i was like joe's a lot to
have his opinion for sure
but you know don't tell people to go to
vouch either
all right let's see turk longwell says
i'd like to nominate tim to do
aoc in a freedom tunes episode about
aoc's big lie in an aoc voice
where is she where is she yeah cause
like you know aoc's story
about the cop coming to the door and
she's like
and there's this bang on the door and
then i hear where is she
i'm like nobody said come on that's
insane but you know what's really
bothering me about the story
like conservatives you know what man
they
they're i know aoc's story
makes no sense for one reason she
claimed it happened a full hour before
the building was breached
why would she assume people would come
to her door a full hour before it even
happened
and even when the writing started 15
minutes
after aoc story occurred the people in
congress
like ted cruz and pelosi had no idea and
were totally calm and were not warned
and nothing was happening
but what i hear from conservatives she
wasn't even the capitol building
she never said she was she said she
thought they were you know made it to
her door because there's tunnels between
the buildings
how about this she claimed the story
happened around 1pm
the the fighting in front of the capital
didn't start till 1 15
and the breaching of the capital didn't
happen until 211.
she psychic why didn't she warn anybody
nobody thought it was going to happen
the story was fake yep
all right let's see we got here marcus
carter says our nation was designed so
that we governed ourselves
but we've handed these roles to the most
corrupt among us we can reclaim our
democracy simply by the uh
simply by those willing and able running
for office and the rest of us supporting
them while rejecting the leaders of the
past that's why they don't like trump
and marjorie taylor green and lauren
bobert because they
they push back they really love using
like the racist and like alt-right and
it's just like
that doesn't mean anything anymore it's
just like the stupidest thing when they
called candace owen
owens white supremacist i'm like but
she's black people are nuts
you know what i don't even i don't even
care blackrock beacon says dune
once men turned their thinking over to
machines in hope that this would set
them free
but that only permitted other men with
machines to enslave them thou shalt not
make a machine the likeness of a human
mind
yes great line have you guys watched the
card
no on paramount spoilers basically
there's like
a lot of artificial life being created
and then
there's a concern that they'll wipe out
because they believe they're superior
and then they'll wipe out organic life
and stuff like that
yeah i mean that's a common concern
right yeah
timmy silverado says tim zubie is
traveling in the u.s are you going to
have him on your show
well zoobee tweeted yes uh dude zooby's
a genius man
no i'm not even kidding i see i see a
bunch of tweets from this there's
there's a reason why his tweets go viral
so often yeah there's there's there's a
few
there's a few things i noticed about
several people on the internet
and it's like something can happen
something can happen
and you'll see within the tribal hive
they have this perspective on it that's
very surface level
and then i'll see something from zooby
where it's like he cracked the core and
like
pulls out this interesting point that no
one considered you know he had that
viral thread whereas like things i
learned during you know covet about you
know
you know about people and it was like i
got 40 000 or like
tens of thousands of retweets i'm like
man we got to have that guy in the show
zooby indeed he is yeah no joke it's
like there's always something he's
putting out
i i was thinking about that i'm liking
that zooby rapper guy's like getting
really big how's
and then you follow his twitter and
you're like oh that's why yeah yeah i
think i follow him on instagram too
all right let's see oh musimoo says i
got an email from friends of desantis a
desantis fundraiser talking about covet
and gain of fouchy research
hilarious pawn and continuation of
desantis's don't fouche my florida shirt
doesn't didn't santa say we shouldn't
have to live under fouchism yep he said
i think yesterday right or today i love
that i love it dude desantis is great i
don't know he's not perfect or whatever
but i love
i love you know i appreciate it yeah uh
that's why i'm like i almost think
he should run and not trump because
trump
has there he has a thing about him that
makes the left naturally the naturally
just wince
desantis is hard to pin down the same
way trump is like
trump they just of course they'll attack
desantis
they'll make a blood after lying like
crazy but they're not going to be as
effective with it trump people know
desantis they're going to be who and the
conservatives know desantis
and he's saying things like this which
is hilarious
michael schwabel says now that lockdowns
are coming back how long until cuomo
puts more people in nursing homes
oh yeah i can only imagine soon right i
mean it worked last time right
okay let's see we got here cobalt joint
replacements what is this
come and get it says after witnessing
cobalt joint replacements firsthand i
will wait a few years as i have lost all
trust in the fda and pharma
they want me to trust them but never
admit fault when they were wrong
interesting
how about that yeah faucism is like
authoritarian incorrectness
it's when you mandate things and then
change them half the time because you
think you're right but you're not
which is you know i guess what
authoritarians do it's a strategy
clef the misfit says with all due
respect can you please stop wholesale
trashing cities
i live in miami i'm proud of my city
we're pretty laid back and
intellectually diverse
we don't have the issues of leftist
cities clef you are 100 percent correct
i stand corrected and you also mentioned
miami right and you know mayor suarez he
really has something going on
florida itself yeah it's a little
different doing pretty well
free country but the weather i love the
weather it's like
i'm all about that weather it's like you
go outside and it's so humid you're
swimming
you're just like whoa it's like living
in slough i was saying lydia on the way
over here but like
yeah that might be true but it also gets
really hot here in florida everybody has
a pool you have a pool your friends have
a pool everybody
has a pool and you're just like whose
pool should we go to to get away from
this weather but you get two months out
of the year to go outside
like january and february no it gets
chilly some places january february i
don't know i was wearing sweatshirts in
january february in florida
driving down the keys is really fun
because like you're you're it's it's
their keys
it's not like the road is built over
water it's it's real fun
when we lived in miami we had i think it
was an egret it like
i guess it got attacked or whatever and
its beak was broken and it landed and it
was stuck in our pool and so we went out
and we had to like gently get him out of
the pool but then he couldn't go
anywhere and he was like too injured
so we called a bird sanctuary we were
like what do we do we got this bird it's
chilling
it's injured but we think it's alive and
he was like well if the injury is
like too much it doesn't matter if it's
healthy now it will die
and so we were like well we don't want
to kill it you know and he was like
well you shouldn't you should bring it
to us and so we drove down to the keys
where there was like a bird sanctuary or
something and then we were like dropped
it off
wow but i guess they killed it gosh darn
it
so close yeah yeah you know these things
happen but at least they tried yeah
that was cool we called them and they're
like we'll see what we can do we'll try
to save the bird it was big it's
you know they're big birds yeah yeah and
it was like it was walking around and
running and we just like
i'm sad you told me that part of the
story andrew gilling says
on leave flying from okinawa to stl and
the flight was oversold
they asked if i would take a different
flight i said to hawaii they agreed
called guys i deployed with and we spent
the night in
a luau you see that's what i'm talking
about that's awesome yeah
dude i've i've been on flights where
they're like 100 bucks you know at first
they're like who will volunteer no one
does 100 bucks to a volunteer no one
does 200
400 800 1200 no one did then finally
they said
if no one accepts the voucher we will
force someone off the plane and you will
lose your seat and it could be you and
still
no one would do it you got to give out
trips to hawaii
i guess what i guess everybody had to be
somewhere yeah
i was working and i'm like i'm here on
business like i i'm not getting i can't
i can't accept that but think about how
desperate they got you could have been
like give me a first class to hawaii and
i'll take it they would have been like
done but it also makes no sense because
wouldn't it just be the person that's
not sitting down that would lose the
seat like
why do they need somebody so badly to
like switch with that person
well because they have 100 seats but
they sold 110 right but the 10 that
aren't sitting are the ones who are you
know here
here's your they assign the same seats
to people um yeah
yeah that happened to me once where i
boarded the plane
and i went and sat down and then someone
came up and had the same seat as me
right
that guy's beat it's like what are you
gonna do you won i got it first yeah did
you get there first yeah yeah cause i
always i mean this is a terrible
business strategy obviously but right
i think southwest does that right they
tell you just to board and then you just
go in and sit down
yeah yeah there was this this great
video i think it's by cgp grey where he
talks about how
our boarding process makes no sense and
it's it's a waste of
time it's a massive waste yeah he was
saying like
even if we board it at random just
saying go on and if you've got a ticket
it would be faster than the way we do it
now
right but the issue is people don't want
to board separately they want to board
with the people they're sitting next to
which makes the whole process cluttered
also you get the people they want to
board the front of the plane first like
section one is the front them two and
three
totally backwards because then
everyone's stuck in the front people
have to wade through the crowd you gotta
bat
you wanna board the back of the plane
first section one then
a little one forward then three and then
the front of the plane last no i think
he said you wanna do window seats middle
seats aisle seats
yeah definitely yeah that's the fastest
way to do it yeah
um because what happens is if you do the
back of the plane then you'll still have
people trying to put their bags up
yeah and then other people waiting
because they got to put their bags in
the same bins yeah if you do aisle seats
they all go in and then go whoop and
then all and then middle rows they all
go in at the same time and then
right on so if you do it by yeah the
problem with that is that they'll
they'll run out of overhead space
and then nobody will want to sit in the
whatever the last one is so
whenever i would uh travel for work when
working for
uh vice it was almost always first class
not because they'd pay for it but
because you get upgraded
but it had to be because if i'm carrying
a thirty thousand dollar camera with me
it has to go in the overhead it can't be
checked it'll be destroyed it can't go
in a closet
and so it's like i had to be up there
standing in the front of the line ready
to go in
otherwise you don't get in the plane
yeah you can't put the cameras in the
you can't check back cameras they break
them
yeah all right let's see horse dude
says people who are going to be evicted
because they didn't pay rent should have
used that unemployment
the bonus the covered relief money
people knew they didn't need to pay a
dime from the eviction
uh moratoriums put in place yeah but i'm
sure there are a lot of people who
[Music]
don't have you know their maybe their
maybe their unemployment benefits
weren't covering the full cost of their
rent
imagine you made six figures and then
your business shuts down because of the
lockdowns
and then all you get is this
unemployment check which is supplemental
so you're still getting a decent amount
yeah
but you can't pay your rent a couple
grand per month and you're like yikes
man
i need a job or imagine you were making
even more than that they cap on
employment at a certain level so the
supplemental plus your cap
could still not be enough for a lot of
people that's why what i was saying when
they were doing the stimulus
they were like we're going to cut people
off who make more than you know x amount
of dollars per year and i was like
that's wrong
right that's like i don't like the idea
of just giving rich people free money
but i also recognize if somebody was
making 120k in new york
they're not considered middle-class
median because new york's cost of living
is so high
and they probably had a moderately
expensive you know rent
that these stimulus checks go no will do
nothing to help them cover their costs
yeah it also makes no sense because they
use the figures before the year before
the pandemic
so like people who like were living the
same life maybe even better
saving money staying home got checks
while people who
you know had made money at a different
time
did not get the checks and it's just
yeah it made no sense they should have
given people who needed it but you know
we can't do that no that's not so that
doesn't make sense
all right let's see woodworker anon says
wait
so pelosi is in charge of the police the
capital so would she have been in charge
of security on the
but there was no backup that day did she
know it was coming not like she had
anything to gain
uh i'm pretty sure it was uh cash patel
said he offered they offered what they
offered national guard
and they turned it down a few days
before and there's that video of the guy
going to the cop saying why aren't you
doing anything about this like where are
the police
so not that she's in charge of it but
because she's a speaker of the house
what's being insinuated is she went to
the police and said this is the rules
the house is saying you have to wear
masks
and the cops were like okay we'll arrest
anybody who doesn't but not on the
senate side
because that means the senate side
didn't make that request
nicholas oh yeah nicholas gay says i
appreciate a lot of what you do tim and
gang
having folks on like bannon schnatter
poso who are vilified by the media
you're able to show how brilliant these
individuals are leaves me speechless
like michael noel's book
oh yeah but you got to realize like
we're we're uh we're getting we get
smeared by the press it's hilarious and
like there's like some hit pieces coming
i just ignore it i don't care
um next tuesday oh yeah
yeah we're confirmed on all this right
we are it's gonna be great charlie kirk
and vosh good yeah so uh
there's like this thing happening on
twitter where they're like charlie kirk
you should go debate this like socialist
guy put your money where your mouth is
and i'm like but he already
he already agreed to do it we're going
to do a show here with charlie and bush
and and vosh is a socialist and we're
going to have that conversation it'll be
a fun time
so i don't think charlie's scared he
immediately agreed
well he like it's it's not so easy to
say he immediately agreed in the sense
that there's still like
business logistics but when he was here
i was like hey man would you want to
come on when we have wash on he was like
yeah like that'd be great like let's see
if we can figure it out and then we
found a date and then we communicate
with both and they're both really
excited and very
professional about it and i imagine it's
going to be
spicy it's going to be great oh you know
maybe i'll
maybe we'll get the uh no i think it'll
be fun
i think i think a lot of people make
assumptions that it's going to be like
wwe
and we've had we've had a few different
leftist personalities here not as many
as like right because it's harder to do
but i think we've had maybe like three
or four yeah and it's always fairly
normal you know it's not crazy destiny
was great he's a smart guy you know he
is that
yeah in high school we had the most
eclectic group of friends like
super liberal crazy super conservative
great crazy like we all got along so
well because we just like the same stuff
we like magic cards and video games and
yeah yeah let's go back to that finding
the same thing's funny
that's gotta be like top priority yeah
exactly i completely agree
making the same jokes
all right let's see okay we read that
one where are we at what was i just
reading no where were we
uh yes rocky says try offering an ultra
woke celebrity five grand to their
favorite leftist cause if they'll put on
a maga hat
then watch the virtue signal dissonance
ooh it's tough yeah
michael irwin says hey guys would l
would love to see y'all do the dnd show
look up harmon quest it's a funny show
ran by dan harmon and features a
different person each show
oh fun that sounds cool i rick and morty
funny yeah yeah
yeah john marafa says
npr equals uh dash national propaganda
radio
ah that's right i can't see it yep
joe harris says look at the fedex logo
between the e and the x
at the arrow now you will see it each
time the curse of the arrow you're
welcome
that was that was the plan that's why
they did it that's not that bad it's
okay i like it
all right we'll do uh we'll get a couple
more in here let's see what we got here
uh oh
ethereal says they just put dave rubin
in twitter jail
they did yeah you know i was thinking
about something
the brandy love story you know the randy
love story i'm not sure
she went to turning point usa and they
they kicked her out oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah uh-huh and i'm seeing a lot of
people say that like
you know oh it's the conservatives are
losing an ally and you know i'm seeing a
lot of people
mention that they're like on brandy
centers when they shouldn't have been
kicked out and i'm like i guess
it doesn't matter what your profession
is if you're attending an event right
but i i suppose what they're saying is
that she was posting and like promoting
and stuff
and that she wasn't clarifying she was
just an attendee but regardless it was
an event for miners
and then i was thinking about this and i
was like i was talking to a friend of
mine who was
you know talking about it was wrong
conservatives should be criticized for
this and i was like
dave rubin band porn on locals yeah
that's like actually kind of crazy to me
because
locals are supposed to be your own
community with your own rules
where you own it you control it and you
can't get shut down but he overtly bans
porn you know i get it you know it's a
bad for the brand i suppose
yeah but if locals is supposed to be
like a semi decentralized node system
where you control your own page
yeah that's not even like hate speech or
anything that's just like well
adult content yeah but it's just so easy
to get you know
into an issue with it right it could be
somebody underage it could be somebody
who didn't consent
like you know it's just too many like
but couldn't he just
say that if we suspected of being a
violation of law we'll remove it but we
allow all other forms of it all
entertainment i don't think so i mean
like there was uh the story where
you know backpage was disappeared
because
they you know had weren't policing the
ads on it
well sure but you know but dave could
say we will police adult content
if we believe it breaks the law which we
will err on the side of
and still allow it yeah it's a brand
it's branding to not allow it
because you could say like oh we we
don't ban hate speech we allow people to
come in and say whatever they want
what if in the event someone actually
calls for violence and instructs people
yeah
you'd have to police that you have to
remove it that's a violation of their
rules so i'm not saying he's right or
wrong to have done it i'm just saying
it's interesting that you know turning
a lot of libertarian type individuals
were critical of turning point usa over
this
and i'm like i don't know there's a lot
of websites that ban this including
locals yeah you know
it's a big debate we headed to mines a
lot like whether or not the original
idea bill was like yeah we should have
anything that's legal it should be on
the site you just need to granularly be
able to
to navigate without getting bombarded by
porn or or violence or whatever or
racism yeah
but it's just hard to tell what's legal
you know exactly especially with porn
[Music]
all right let's see let's do this one
more
uh what is this the tdy says could
mandating vaccines benefit small
businesses not run by big corporations
mandating vaccine
i could see this taking business from a
starbucks and move it to a local coffee
business would be funny
interesting if the local business if the
smaller business says that it's you know
easy free or an open and the big chain
say no
then that might actually you know happen
but uh
we'll see how about this we're gonna go
over to timcast.com to the members only
segment we should be up around 11 and
talk about the forbidden wall street
journal article
that youtube would not permit but we're
going to talk about it's very important
among other things so go to timcast.com
become a member don't forget smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
and you can follow the show at tim cast
irl on facebook and instagram you can
follow me personally at
tim cast the show is live monday through
friday at 8pm leave us a good review on
itunes or spotify
if you're listening and carol do you
want to shout anything out uh no thank
you so much for having me this was
really great your twitter account maybe
it's uh at carol k-a-r-o-l wow
you've been on since the beginning yeah
yeah yeah
i think so i mean you know 2007. uh no
no i
actually wasn't that earned was not that
early in adopter i somehow snagged it
wow it's impressive uh you can follow me
at ian crossland.net and at ian
crossland and i want to shout out
dr ace thayer from socal chiropractic
a youtube channel that i absolutely love
he's got magic hands he fixes people's
spines on the daily
and uh go subscribe to his channel and
check that out if you like watching
people get their
their bodies fixed interesting you guys
are more than welcome to follow me on
twitter
at sourpatchlids i am about to adopt a
cat
tomorrow and i will be posting all sorts
of adventures he's an ornery little
stinker so it's gonna be fun his name is
dip
i am buying that dip and i'm stoked
and i my goal is to uh have more
followers than sour patch kids so by all
means help me with that
thanks guys we will see you all at
timcast.com in the members only podcast
segment
thanks for hanging out we'll see you
there bye guys
you